ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA POWER QUE HAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRKS THE
RAMOS RAY YES THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH. STONE
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND. WELL EVERYONE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. THERE ARE MOMENTS
THAT REMIND US THAT ALL THINGS
ARE TO THE ONE IN THE CYCLE OF
LIFE. THIS IS THE LESSONS IN
THE STORY OF THE LION KING BUT
ALSO WHEN I HEARD YEARS AGO
FROM A YOUNG CHILD. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE I RETURN FROM
JAPAN AND WAS ASSIGNED TO THE
LARGEST TEMPLE IN LOS ANGELES.
I REMEMBER VERY EARLY ON
OFFICIATING THE CEMETERY
SERVICE FOR ONE OF THE TEMPLES
SENIOR MEMBERS. AS WE WATCHED
IN QUIET REVERENCE AS THE
CASKET WAS BEING LOWERED I FELT
THE SLEEVE OF MY ROLE BEING
TUGGED. IT WAS A SEVEN YEAR OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER WHO WAS STANDING
NEXT TO ME. WHEN OUR EYES MET.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO GRANDPA.
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO SAY I ASKED
HER WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY'RE
DOING. SHE BECAME EVEN MORE
OBSERVANT. THAN WITH A KNOWING
SMILE SHE TURNED TO ME AND
SAID. I KNOW WE ARE PLANTING
GRANDPA AND GRANDPA IS GOING TO
BECOME TREES AND GRASS AND
FLOWERS. HER RESPONSES SO
INNOCENT IN PEER. IT WAS ALSO
REFRESHING AND REAL WORDS
REFLECTED THE NATURAL CYCLE AND
THE ONENESS OF ALL LIFE I COULD
ONLY SAY TO HER I REALLY LIKE
THAT A LOT. AND WE BOTH SMILED.
HER WISDOM HAS NEVER LEFT ME
EVEN AFTER FORTY FOUR YEARS HER
KNOWING SMILE STILL WARMS MY
HEART. AND REMINDS ME THAT ALL
OF US OWN LIFE IN ALL THINGS WE
ARE INSEPARABLE IN THE CYCLE OF
LIFE. NOW MORE ME WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. FOUND
OVER HEART. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. OR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY AUGUST
NINETEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY MET AT ONE PM I WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHEAPER
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DESK
READING CLICK CAPPING AND WAS
READING. THE ROLL CALL AS I AM
REQUIRED TO THE CURRENT YOUR
CALL THEIR OWN MOVES AND MISTER
FLORES SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE. ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
APPLICANTS IS TODAY. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR EMOTIONS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS A LOWMOAN AND
QUIRK SILVA TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GALLAGHER
WALDRON ARAMBULA. BLOOM EGGMAN
VOEPEL AND WICKS TO SPEAK ON IN
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILL SOME INACTIVE
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE HILL AT THE REQUEST
OF THE SOMEONE BONTA IN ITEM
ONE SIX SB. ONE SEVENTY NINE
NEIL. AT THE REQUEST OF A
MEMBER. QUESTION IS CONSENT TO
ORDER HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY
FOUR SMITH TO THE THIRD READING
FILE. MR FLORA FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DID PASS WE WITHHOLD UNIONS
CONSENT NATURAL CALL THE QUE
THANK YOU. MISTER CALDERON
MOVES. AND THAT HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY FOUR SMITH GO
TO THE THIRD READING FILE AND
MISS RUBIO SECONDS WE WILL TAKE
A ROLL CALL VOTE. MOTION TO
SUSPEND THE RULES CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER. CALDERON
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE OR ASK FOR A
NO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FORTY FIVE KNOWS NINE THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED AGAIN EVERYBODY'S TO
WAKING UP ALL RIGHT. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND
THE ACTION WHERE BY ALL AUGUST
TWENTY SECOND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
ROCK WAS READ A THIRD TIME AND
PASSED THE SENATE I ASK THAT
THE BILL BE RETURNED TO THE
THIRD READING FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RECEIVE ACTUAR BY
ENGINE. TWENTY SEVEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN S. THREE NINETY NINE.
THIS IS RIGHT UP THERE. THE
SENATE I ASKED ABOUT THAT BILL.
BE RETURNED TO THIRTY FILES ALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. THERE IS A LIST OF
BILLS AT THE DESK THE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS PENDING I ASKED THAT
THE READING CLERK READ THE
BILLS. THAT WE ADOPTED THE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT WEEK THAT
THEY GO OUT TO PRINT AND BE
PLACED BACK ON THE FILE.
HEARING NO OBJECTION THE CLERK
WILL READ THE BILL'S WITH
AMENDMENTS. FIVE SEVENTY NINE
SIMPLE SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WITH
THE MEMONS BY SELLING THEM
PEACHY NORRIS FINAL EIGHTY FIVE
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THREE
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOME MEMBER
KALRA. FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GALLAGHER. FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE SENATE BILL TWO TWELVE
WITH THE MEMBERS BY SOME
REMEMBER TO. FILE ITEM ONE OR
TWO SIMPLE FORTY FIVE WITH THE
MINUTES BY SELLING OUR JONES
SAWYER. FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER LACKEY. FILE ITEM ONE
TEN SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX WITH THE MEMONS BY SELLING
OVER LOW. FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN
SENATE BILL SEVENTY WITH THE
MA'AM IT'S BASICALLY MEMBER
BLOOM. FIND ONE TWENTY NINE
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO WITH
THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING OVER
THE- THREE OF US. BOTTOM ONE
THIRTY SENATE BILL FIVE WITH
THE MEMONS BUT REMEMBER MULLIN.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE
SENATE BILL FORTY NINE WITH THE
MEN. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY SIX
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER MEDINA. FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY ONE SIMPLE THREE FORTY
NINE WHAT THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS. FIVE A
ONE SIXTY SIX IN ABOUT THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WITH THE MEMBERS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH. BOTTOM
ONE SEVENTY SENATE BILL FOUR OF
SEVEN WITH THE MEMBERS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER WOULD. FIVE A
ONE SEVENTY ONE SIMPLE FOR
SIXTEEN WITH THE MEMONS
BASICALLY MEMBER GETS IN. FIVE
A ONE SEVENTY TWO SYMBOL FOR
TWENTY FIVE WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER. FIND
ONE SEVENTY FOUR SIMPLE FOR
FORTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
CITY AMERICA'S ALL IS. FILE
ITEM. ONE EIGHTY FOUR SIMPLE
FIVE THIRTY TWO WITH THE MEMONS
BASICALLY MEMBERS DOWN. ONE
EIGHTEEN SIMPLE FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BASICALLY
MEMBER CARILLO. FIVE I NINETY
THREE SENATE BILL SIX HUNDRED
WITH THE MEMONS BASICALLY
MEMBER WICKS. BY ADAM TO TWENTY
SIX AND A ONE FIFTY WITH THE
MINUTES BASED ON THE NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. BOTTOM TO TWENTY
SEVEN SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
NINE WITH THE MEMONS BASICALLY
AMERICANS AND- I'M TO TWENTY
NINE ZERO ONE SIXTY THREE WITH
THE MEMONS BASICALLY MEMBERS.
BOTTOM TWO FIFTY SIX AND ABOUT
THREE NINETY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS BASICALLY MEMBER OF OUR
QUE. FIFTY NINE SYMBOL FOR
FIFTY THREE WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN. AND
FILE ITEM TO SEE. ABOUT FIVE
THIRTY ONE WITH THE MEMBERS BY
SOME MEMBER MURATSUCHI. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE EYES IT THE
BILLS ARE OUT OF PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE. MEMBERS PRESENT WAS
REAL SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
I'M REFERRING ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE AB TWELVE SIXTY
FOUR BY MISS PETRIE-NORRIS TO
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE
. MEMBERS WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY. MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. BAKER AND MEMBERS
MEMBERS TODAY I AM SO PROUD TO
HONOR AND TO RECOGNIZE MY CHIEF
OF STAFF JOHN SCRIBNER WHO IS
RETIRING AFTER TWENTY TWO YEARS
OF SERVICE. MANY JOHN FOR HIS
WIT AND FOR HIS JOKES IN FOR
OUR CANDY BASKET BUT HE IS MUCH
MORE THAN THAT HE IS KNOWN FOR
IS MENTORING OF MANY CHIEFS OF
STAFF HE'S ALSO KNOWN FOR HIS
ARE VERY VERY ROBUST AT MALENE.
DEPARTMENT THAT HE HAS LEARNED
TO BE A WITH THAT BUT JOHN
JOINED OF MY TEAM IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN HE ALSO HAS WORKED WITH
MEMBERS DON PERATA SCOTT. WHILE
THE MEN GLORIA MCGREADY MACLEOD
JIMMY GOMEZ AND STATE SENATORS
RON CALDERON AND LIEU QUREIA AS
YOU MAY KNOW WHAT THOSE NAMES
SOME OF THEM HAVE ALSO MOVED ON
TO CONGRESS. AS CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN IS SERVE THE CONSTITUENTS
IN THE SIXTY FIFTH DISTRICT
INCREDIBLY WELL I JUST HEARD
TODAY FROM ONE OF MY MEMBERS
FROM WHAT A PARK WHO HAPPENS TO
BE THE TEAMSTERS CHAIR THAT HE
RECEIVED A BIRTHDAY CARD OVER
FIFTY FIVE. MAY ALL FROM IN OUR
DISTRICT AND HE WAS HAPPY TO
NOTE THAT THAT'S ONE OF JOHN
SPECIALTY IT'S IN ADDITION
THOSE OF US WHO KNOW JOHN IS
THAT THAT HE STARTED NOT ONLY
IN THE BUILDING TWENTY TWO
YEARS AGO BUT MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS AGO AS A YOUNG MAN
EXCITED ABOUT POLITICS. WORKING
IN EVERY AVENUE FROM CAMPAIGNS
TO ADVOCACY TO KNOCKING ON
DOORS AND CONTINUES THAT
PASSION. HE HAS RECENTLY
RECEIVED THE RESPECT FROM HIS
COLLEAGUES AND PEERS AGAIN AS I
SAID BECAUSE OF HE HAS A WAY
WITH LISTENING IN OUR BUILDING
SO HE'S ABLE TO GATHER MUCH
INFORMATION FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE THAT WE KNOW HAS
SERVED US WELL. AND JOHN IS
ALSO KNOWN FOR IS BIPARTISAN
RELATIONSHIPS AND AGAIN AS WE
BECOME A BODY OF NORMALLY
LEGISLATORS WORKING ACROSS THE
AISLE IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE OF UP
WE WERE HAPPY TO SURPRISE JOHN
THIS MORNING WITH HIS DAUGHTER
FLYING IN. TODAY AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE BOTH OF HIS
DAUGHTERS HERE TODAY HIS WHAT I
HAD TO STAY HOME AS THEIR DOG
YEAH. IS THAT OF THAT BUT WE
KNOW JOHN JOHN RUN HOME TO MAKE
SURE THAT SALT ORDER BUT PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME. BUDDY WHO.
MONICA CHIEFS OF STAFF SOMEBODY
HAS SERVED ME AND MANY OTHERS
INCREDIBLY WELL JOHN SCRIBNER
.
MISTER NAZARIAN REASON YOUR
RICE ADAM SPEAKER. IF WE DENY
THIS REQUEST DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THE RETIREMENT IS
SUSPENDED. I DON'T THINK WE CAN
DO THAT. ASK MR AND MISTER
WILSON IS NOT HERE BUT WE WOULD
HAVE TRIED THAT IN HIS CASE AS
WELL. MISTER COOPER FOR PURPOSE
DERIVE. JUST RECOGNIZE MISTER
SCRIBNER I'VE KNOWN JOHN FOR A
LONG TIME WHEN I WAS WE WERE
BOTH INVOLVED IN GOOGLE
SOFTBALL JOHN COURSES DAUGHTERS
NOT COAST LINE AND JUST THINK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME JOHN TO THE
CAPITAL VERY BUSY EVERY DAY YOU
HAVE THE TIME TO GO HOME AND
COACHES DOLLARS TO BE INVOLVED.
WHEN I FIRST CAME LEGISLATURE
JOHN WAS VERY VERY THANKFUL TO
ME AND APPROACHED ME AND JUST
APPRECIATE ALL JOHN'S EFFORTS
AND- ENJOY YOUR TIME AND THE
GUY. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU MISTER SCRIBNER FOR
YEARS SERVICE TO THIS BODY INTO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ANOTHER
IMPORTANT INTRODUCTION MISS THE
MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE. TO RECOGNIZE BILL HERMAN
WHO IS RETIRING FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AFTER TWENTY YEARS OF
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AFTER OF NUMBER OF
EXCITING STOPS ALONG HIS CAREER
PATH INCLUDING SERVICE SERVICE
SERVING AS A NUCLEAR REACTOR
OPERATOR ON A US NAVY
SUBMARINE. AND OPERATING
LOBSTER DISTRIBUTION BUSINESS.
BILL LEFT HIS GRADUATE PROGRAM
AT UC SANTA BARBARA TO JOIN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. WHILE
WORKING ON GAME IMPACT CONTACTS
AT THE LA ILL BILL FORGE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP TEAM THAT EVENTUALLY
BROUGHT HIM INTO THE BUILDING
AS A CHIEF CONSULTANT ON THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES THE
BILL HAS ALWAYS ANSWER THE CALL
OF DUTY. WHETHER ASKED TO SERVE
AS THE CHIEF OF STAFF OR TO PUT
IT BACK INTO COMMITTEE SYSTEM
THE BILL HAS RISEN TO THE
OCCASION AND HAZARD. THIS
INSTITUTION WITH HONOR AND
RESPECT. ALTHOUGH HE WAS
TEMPORARILY PULLED AWAY TO
SERVE AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS BILL
FOUND HIS WAY BACK TO THE PLACE
WHERE DEMOCRACY HAPPENS. OVER
MY THREE YEARS ON THE BANKING
COMMITTEE AND TWO YEARS AS
CHAIR I HAVE BENEFITTED GREATLY
AND I MEAN GREAT FROM BILLS
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE AND
KNOWLEDGE. HE HAS ALSO SERVED
AS A MENTOR TO MY PERSONAL
STAFF AND IS A SOURCE OF VERY
POSITIVE ENERGY WITH ENGAGING
CONVERSATION IN THE OFFICE. THE
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO YOU. ON BEHALF OF
DOZENS OF MEMBERS. FORMER
MEMBERS AND STAFFERS IN THANK
YOU FOR APPROACHING YOUR
EVERYDAY WORK IN THIS
INSTITUTION WITH RESPECT AND
INTEGRITY. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND WISH YOU WELL
IN YOUR RETIREMENT AND DO YOU
HOPE THAT YOUR RETIREMENT TAKES
YOU TO VISIT SANTA BARBARA SOON.
WITH THAT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
BILL WITH A RESOLUTION BUT ALSO
INVITE ANY FOCUS AND- HERE TO
RECEPTION ROOM THREE SEVENTEEN
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE NOW UNTIL
ABOUT ELEVEN THIRTY. SO THANK
YOU. IS GARCIA FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THE RICE. I ALSO RISE TO
RECOGNIZE BILLS OPERAS SERVICE
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY. I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH BILL
WHEN HE WAS THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THAT KIND OF
ABILITY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE. I WHEN I WAS
TRYING IT AND LIKE MISS THEM ON
I GOT TO ENJOY. HIS POSITIVE
ENERGY BUT HE BRINGS A COMMON
ENERGY TO ANY PLACES THAT BUT
HE'S WILLING TO GO TO BATTLE
WITH YOU I AND I'M IN A HEART
BEAT AS WELL I GOT TO SEE HOW
YOU MENTORED NOT JUST A SLAP IN
THE COMMITTEE BUT ALL THE SAID
INCLUDING A NUMBER OF TEAM VERY
CM MEMBERS. AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
IN MY OFFICE THAT ONE'S GRACIE
ALWAYS SEEM GARCIA AND BUILT IN
THAT PRISON EVERYTHING WE
NEEDED HIM I EVEN THOUGH HE'S
NO LONGER PART OF MICE THAT HE
HAS RISEN TO THE OCCASION IN
THIS OP IS NOT ALONG THE WAY.
SO WE ALL REALLY LIKE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE BILL DOES
COMMITMENT TO DEMOCRACY THAT IS
COMMITMENT TO THE INSTITUTION
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY TO HAVE
HIS OPENNESS TO HELP ANYONE OUT
TO SIXTY HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND SO ON BEHALF OF MYSELF ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTLESS
STAFFERS YOU HAVE MENTORED. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS YOUR
WORK INTO THEIR GREAT ENERGY
YOU BRING ALONG EVERYDAY. TO
THE JOB. CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR RETIREMENT
. THANK YOU
MISTER HERMS FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO THE STATE AND TO US. I WILL
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE SECOND READING FILE ITEM
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. THE ALL
BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. FILE
ITEM TWO AB NINE OH NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE OH NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
GALLAGHER AND ACTUALLY TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB NINE
OH NINE WILL HELP ENSURE
CAMPAIGN TREASURES UNDERSTAND
THEIR LIABILITIES BY REQUIRING
THEM TO SIGN A STATEMENT
OUTLINING WHAT THEY WILL BE
HELD LIABLE FOR AND THE
POTENTIAL PALIN PENALTIES FOR
FAILING TO COMPLY. THE NAME IS
TAKEN THE SENATOR MINOR
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND ENSURE
THE BILL FUNCTIONS AS INTENDED
AB NINE OH NINE IS SPONSORED BY
THE F. PPC AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THREE AB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ I SOME LEGAL SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY TO
HOMELESSNESS MR SANTIAGO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEN
SPEAKER AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW HOMELESS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS TO ENGAGE IN
PREVENTION EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO ON THE VERGE OF
BEING HOMELESSNESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LETTING FOR AB
FOR SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SOMETHING ALL FOR SIXTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE AND ACTUALLY THE
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. IS EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MANISTIQUE REMEMBERS A BEFORE
SIXTY SIX IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE WITH DOCTOR CONCURRENT
HAVING TO DO WITH AGRICULTURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FIVE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM SIX. AB
EIGHT NINETY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ AS A LEGAL EIGHT NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE REAL PROPERTY.
IS THERE HOPE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING THE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR EIGHT NINETY TWO. FOR
CONCURRENCE THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE UPDATE THE CODE TO
ENSURE MULTIPLE LISTING SERVICE
THAT RETAIN. THEIR RECORDS ADDS
CLARITY TO THE APPLICABILITY OF
TRANSFERRED X. CLOSER
STATEMENTS. AND MADE OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. THE BILL
HAS PASSED BOTH HOUSES WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ZERO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTER CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THOUGH IT AYE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASSING A
CHAIN ON FILE ITEM SEVEN FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB ELEVEN FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
LEVIN FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AND ACTUALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. MR GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FIGURE OUT A SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN FIFTY IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY WAS
CAST FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FIFTY TWO KNOWS NINE SEND
HAVE A FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND SENATOR ON THE FLOOR WE'D
LIKE TO WELCOME FORMER SENATOR
MARK RIDLEY THOMAS. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NINE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE COLLEGIATE
ATHLETES MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SAID TODAY
I PRESENT AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE FOR CONCURRENCE. THIS
BILL GIVES COLLEGE ATHLETES
TOOLS AND LEGAL PROTECTION TO
ADDRESS ANY CHALLENGES ABUSES
RETALIATION OR OTHER UNFAIR
PRACTICES THEY MAY FACE ON
CAMPUS. WE CONSIST CONSTANTLY
SEE EXAMPLES OF COLLEGE STUDENT
ATHLETES DEALING WITH ABUSE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS IN A WAY. IN A NEW WAY
BY EDUCATING AND EQUIPPING
COLLEGE ATHLETES TO BE EVEN
BETTER ADVOCATES FOR THEMSELVES
OF PROTECTING THEM AS THEY DO
IT. SENATE AMENDMENTS INCREASE
PROTECTIONS FOR DO NOW FLEETS
THAT ARE VICTIMS OF HARASSMENT.
TESTIFYING AGAINST ABUSE AND
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE I SIXTY FIVE
NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LATE IN TEN
EIGHTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER MR GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED HIM AS SPEAKER
MEMBERS A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY A.
YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER TO. THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB THREE NINETY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL THREE
NINETY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
VOEPEL AND ACTUALLY TO RENTED
VEHICLES MR VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENT TO YOU AB THREE
NINE ONE THAT IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CAN CURRENCY
AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL AND
INCLUDE A SUNSET PROVISION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER REPEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IT.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AJ ARE SIXTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. IS ON THE
JOINT RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BASED
ON THE NUMBER THREE OF US AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE MYSTERY OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AG ARE SIXTEEN
COMMEMORATES THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO ADD
ADDITIONAL CO AUTHORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
HOMELESSNESS THE THREE OF US
HERE AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB FIFTY EIGHT IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER
TAKING A CHAPTER IN OUT
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE THE
BILL ADDS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING FINANCE
COUNCIL AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RIVAS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
ONE SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY THE NEW MOTOR
VEHICLES MISS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT AB
ONE SEVEN NINE A BILL THAT
UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S NEW MOTOR
VEHICLE FRANCHISE LAWS. THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT THE BALANCE
OF POWER BETWEEN CAR
MANUFACTURERS AND CAR NEW DO
YOU CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERS IS BALANCED AND ENSURES
ADEQUATE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS FOR
BOTH PARTIES. THIS BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF DOZENS OF HOURS OF
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
SPONSOR AND AUTOMAKERS SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVED THE
PROVISION RELATING TO THIRD
PARTY WARRANTY PROVIDERS AND
MADE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RARE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBER THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
AB TWO FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ AS A LABEL TO FORTY ONE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE THAN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS THIS
CON LONGER DAD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'M HERE TODAY ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR ONE
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
MAKE TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS AN
EXAM COURSES THAT ARE NOT
DEDICATED SOLELY TO PATIENT
CARE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COM
LONGER DAD SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THAT VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLEAR WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY ONE KNOWS TO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB ONE
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY SIX BY
SELLING MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
THIS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
AB ONE THIRTY SIX IN RESPONSE
TO THE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
SCANDAL IS BACK ON CURRENT
CONCURRENCE. JUST A REMINDER
ABOUT THIS BILL AB ONE THIRTY
SIX PROHIBITS CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE NAMED IN THE
FEDERAL INDICTMENT AND FOUND
GUILTY FROM BENEFITING FROM A
LEGAL INCOME TAX CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTION OR BUSINESS
EXPENSE THIS. DEDUCTIONS SENATE
AND AMENDMENTS ARE CLEAR FINE
AND TECHNICAL. I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU QUIRK
SILVA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO SAN IN
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO SIXTY TWO
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIXTY TWO BY FAMILY
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH. MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWO SIXTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT SO AFTER MINUTES
WERE TAKEN IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED THAT THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS MADE BY A
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER LUKE AND
REQUIRE COMPLIANCE WITH ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS.
THIS BILL IS TWO YEARS IN THE
MAKING FOLLOWING THE TRAGIC
DEATH OF TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK.
THIS BILL WILL HELP SAVE LIVES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
AB FOR THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY
BY SOME THE MEMBER GALLAGHER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. WHEN THE
CAMPFIRE DISPLAYS FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HOMES I KNEW THAT IT WAS GONNA
TAKE SIGNIFICANT ACTION. TO
SPUR HOUSING IN THIS REGION.
AND I AM VERY THANKFUL TO THIS
BODY FOR THE WORK THAT WE DID
ON THIS BILL AB FOR THIRTY
WHICH WOULD. STREAMLINED OF
FAST TRACK HOUSING PROJECTS IN
THE CAMPFIRE REGION. I IN
SPECIFIED CITIES. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE THE CHAIR OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE WHO
WHO WORKED WITH ME VERY CLOSELY
ON THIS BILL. FOLKS OVER IN THE
SENATE WHO. MADE SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES IN MAY THIS
BILL EVEN BETTER. I THINK WE
HAVE A GREAT TOOL HERE THAT'S
GOING TO HELP A LOT OF FOLKS AS
A HELP AS THEY SEEK TO RECOVER
FROM THE MOST DEVASTATING FIRE.
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TO SEND THIS ON TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS APPROVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE IN THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NOSE
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER NAZARIAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HEAL
ARTS MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW LICENSED OPTOMETRIST TO
BRING VISION SERVICES AND
TESTING TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONFINED TO THEIR HOMES SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM TWENTY AB FOR
EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER MEDINA AND
pMR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. AB FOR
EIGHTY FIVE EXPANDS CURRENT LAW
TO INFORM THE PUBLIC WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION BEFORE
LOCAL DISTRICTS APPROVED
TAXPAYER FUNDER. SUBSIDIES FOR
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE THE DRESS THE OPPOSITION
CONCERNING REGARDING
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION AS A
RESULT CAL CHAMBER AND THE
CALIFORNIA REALTORS ASSOCIATION
OF GUN NEUTRAL AND THE CITY OF
FRESNO IS IN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY TWO KNOWS ELEVEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB FIVE
AWAIT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
ACTUALLY DRINKING WATER. MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE ZERO
A IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENT PROVIDE
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY TO
RESIDENTS IN THAT THIS THIS
ADVANTAGE COMMUNITY CONSIDERING
A CONSOLIDATION OR EXTENSION OF
SERVICES BY REQUIRING THE WATER
BOARD TO DESCRIBE THE WATER
QUALITY COME TURN. AND
ASSOCIATED HEALTH THE FACT OF
THE WATER CONTAMINANT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT THROUGH
THE PROPOSED PROJECT IN
ADDITION TO AMENDMENT CLARIFY
DOES THE WATER BOARD CAN ALL
ALL DREW A CONCERT A
CONSOLIDATION OR EXTENSION OF
SERVICES. UNTIL DO WELL OWNER
CONSENT. TO THE PROJECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AUDIBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY NINE NEWS TEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN BY
LETTING TWENTY TWO AB FIVE
SIXTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY BY
SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE UNION
ORGANIZING. MISTER SANTIAGO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU
MEANT SPEAKER THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB FIVE SEVEN
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING NUMBER EIGHT
MEN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
MATERNAL HEALTH THIS EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAN SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
HAVING TO DO WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH TO MATCH CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASSING A CHAIN ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ AS
LEGAL SIX TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND I CLING TO PEOPLE
AND STUDENT HEALTH. MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I AM PLEASED
TODAY PERCENT AB SIXTY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY
FOR CONCURRENCE AMONG OTHER
CHANGES SENATE AMENDMENT TO ADD
CO AUTHORS AND CREE PARAMETERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IS BOTH SCIENTIFICALLY.
BASED AND COMPREHENSIVE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBER THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES EYES FIFTY KNOWS TWELVE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
SEVEN OH THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ I SOME PEOPLE SEVEN OH
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SEVEN OH THREE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE WOMEN'S
CLARIFY WHO'S ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE EIGHT UNDER THIS BILL.
IT HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTE IN
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT AB EIGHT NINETY
NINE PURPLE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY NINE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER WOULD AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES SIR WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT NINETY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE.
THE ADDITION THAT A REQUIREMENT
THE REQUIREMENT AT A FACILITY
CHOIR BY LICENSE CLINICALLY
LICENSED TO EITHER THE
AFFILIATE OR CONSOLIDATED
CLINIC LICENSE PROCESS AND
HAVING HAD HAVING BEEN SEEN
PATIENTS WITHIN THE PREVIOUS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. MISTER WED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER OPEN. THE
WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE THE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE AB
NINE FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SOMETHING ALL NINE FORTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING AND
ACTUALLY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
SIR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB NINE FORTY SIX IS
IN ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL
CONTAINING MINOR AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGE TO AVOID CHAPTER
PROBLEMS WITHOUT THE BILL'S.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A BOAT.
THANK YOU FOR BERMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK. ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE INTELIGO AYE SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB NINE SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ SELLABLE NINE SEVENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER SALAS AND ACTING
TO AGING THIS IS ALICE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT
TO HELP SENIORS GET TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN IVAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO AB TEN THIRTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL TEN
THIRTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND I TOOK THE STATE
GOVERNMENT MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN THIRTEEN
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE. IT
IMPLEMENTS IN AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND OPPOSES A
TWO YEAR MORATORIUM FOR ANYONE
SERVING AS A GRANT EVALUATOR
WHO IS ALSO A STAFF MEMBER OR
BOARD MEMBER OF THE
ORGANIZATION APPLYING FOR THE
GRANT SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
MINOR IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
RAISED BY THE STAKEHOLDER
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS CRUCIAL
PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
OVER ANTI SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL IN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TEN
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING ALL TEN FOURTEEN BY
SOME AMBER O'DONNELL AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY HEALTH FACILITIES.
MR O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS AB TEN FOURTEEN
REQUIRES HOSPITALS THAT PROVIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES TO
PROVIDE A ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAY NOTICE TO THE
PUBLIC. PRIOR TO REDUCING OR
ELIMINATING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. SENATE MEMBERS REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF DAYS A HOSPITAL'S
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE NOTICE
PRIOR TO READ THE LOCATING
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES. AND
DELETED THE ONE HUNDRED AND A
REQUIREMENT FOR A HOSPITAL TO
MAKE REASONABLE EFFORTS TO
INFORM THE COMMUNITY OF A
CHANGER CLOSER. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. MR BRO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB TEN FOURTEEN PROUD
TO WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND TO SPEND THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS FOR HOSPITAL CLOSING AND
NINETY DAYS FOR ELIMINATION OF
EXISTING SERVICE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SADDLEBACK MORAL CENTER
MY DISTRICT CLOSE A HOSPITAL
CLOSER PUT MANY MEDICAL WORKERS
ADAM JOB AND LEFT NEARLY FORTY
MILES BETWEEN MISSION. AND
OCEANSIDE WITHOUT ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY ROOM I RESPECT LAST
YEAR. THANK YOU MISTER BRO.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE OF. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FIFTY TWO NO SIX
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB
TWELVE FIFTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ AS A LEVEL TWELVE FIFTY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND OTHERS AND I PLAN TO BUY
MENTAL PROTECTION. THE SERVICE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FIFTY TWO ALLOWS THE
DISTRIBUTION OF A OF A OF
ADVANCE GRANT PAYMENTS FROM
CALLIE PA TO NON PROFITS OR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. THESE PAYMENTS ARE
WATER FOR PROJECTS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT EXPOSURE TO I'M-
POLLUTION SORRY. SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE A
CLARIFICATION RELATED TO
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY FOR NON.
THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. I WOULD NONPROFIT
STATUS AND FURTHER. THIS BILL
THROUGH THESE AMENDMENTS IT
CLARIFIES THE RELATED GRANT
PAYMENTS AND IN SUCH TERMS THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED THE FULL
SUPPORT THE SENATE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR SUPPORT IN THIS BECAUSE
VOTE. THEY CAN MENTION THANK
YOU MISTER RIVAS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTIES
YOU KNOW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN WILL PASS
ENTERTAINMENT FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AND ACTUALLY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SOME NEED IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND THEN IT'S IN
THE SENATE WERE MINOR AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE.
THANK YOU. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FOR THAT. MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ A CYNICAL
THIRTEEN NINETEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER ARAMBULA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE MIGRANT
EDUCATION THIS ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
WILL PROVIDE AN OPTION FOR
MIGRANT STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THEIR ACADEMICS AT THE SCHOOL
OF ORIGINAL ENROLLMENT AND
CONTINUE TO MATRICULATE INTO
THEIR ORIGINAL SCHOOL. DESPITE
A CHANGE IN RESIDENTS AB
ROUTINE NINETEEN SIX TO MANY
EYES ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
DISRUPTIONS FOR MIGRANT
STUDENTS GIVING THEM THE OPTION
TO REMAIN IN THEIR SCHOOL
DESPITE MOVING. AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SIR
ARAMBULA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
WELL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
BLOOM AND ACTUALLY THE
RESIDENTIAL REAL PROPERTY. SIR
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE IS HERE ON
CONCURRENT FROM THE SENATE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE CLARIFYING. AND TECHNICAL
IN NATURE THE BILL MAKES CAR
FIGHT CHANGES TO THE ELLIS ACT
THAT ARE INTENDED TO BOTH
ENSURE FAIRNESS. FOR TENANTS.
AND REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR BOTH
LAUGH LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THIS
BILL PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR
LANDLORDS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TENANTS AND PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL SECURITY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO
DISPLACEMENT. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION THE REALTORS AND THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION ARE
NEUTRAL I THANK YOU AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRED. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY NINE NEWS
TENDS SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASSING RETAIN AND
FILE ITEM FORTY FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN OH FIVE TWICE ON THE
MEMBER TING AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION MISTER
TEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIXTEEN OH
BY THE DISTRICT BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES THE- CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO TO ESTABLISH A-
REVISION PROGRAM TO MANAGE. ALL
OF OUR MOST FAMOUS STREETS
LOMBARD STREET. IT'S THE AB THE
BILL IS BACK FOR THE CURRENT
FROM THE SENATE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED A SEVEN YEAR
SUNSET AND DIRECTS PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS. TO EXPLORE
OPTIONS FOR MAINTAINING
ACCESSIBILITY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY LAST FRIDAY. THANK
YOU MISTER KING SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THOSE GUYS FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ A SOME LEGAL SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GRAYSON AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION MR GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER ARISE TODAY IS
THE BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. RISK.
FIND THE INTO THE BILL TO
REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES. SOME
PEOPLE USE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I WOULD KILEY REQUESTER
HI. VOTE ON AB SIXTY. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOSE AYE SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ AS LEGAL
SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION MISTER
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD ALLOW
CALTRANS C. H. P. AND
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE ON ROAD TESTING. OF
TRUCK PLATOONING TECHNOLOGIES
BY EXTENDING THE CURRENT SUNSET
TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
IN THE BILL. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON CURRENT
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER BERMAN. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOMETHING
WILL SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY HOUSING. IS
YOUR CAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE SIX TO
EXTEND THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
CITY IS SOUNDS A TO BUILD
EMERGENCY BRIDGE HOUSING
COMMUNITIES FROM JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TO JANUARY
FIRST THE FIVE AMENDMENTS TAKE
IN THE SENATE. I SENATORS ABOUT
ON WHAT OTHERS MIGHT BE ASKED
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING MR TO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
DELETE THE OPTION FOR
DEVELOPERS TO REQUEST AN
ENHANCE DENSITY BONUS WITHIN A
HALF MILE BUS QUARTERS. LIMIT
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR A 100%
AFFORDABLE SPECIAL NEEDS
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
WANT TO THANK THE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR
A FEW MONTHS AGO AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AGAIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
BEING IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERT VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING THE AYE
AYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS NINE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. ORDER PASADENA AND FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX. FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN AB EIGHTEEN NO ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN OH ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
ACTUALLY THE CATTLE MAKING A
PROBATION THERE FOR THE SEGMENT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TAKE YOUR
VETERANS SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
EIGHT OH ONE IS THE BACK ON
CONCURRENT HAVING TO DO WITH.
AGRICULTURE AND CATTLE I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS EGGMAN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIRTY WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES SIXTEEN KNOWS ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ A SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN FORTY NINE BY FAMILY
MEMBER MARK STONE AND OTHERS AN
EXCELLENT SELECTIONS IT'S JUST
DOWN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I MEMBERS. AB
SEVEN FORTY NINE IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
IS THE BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT. A NO REHIRE CLAUSE TO
BE PUT IN A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WHEN SOMEONE HAS
BROUGHT A CASE FOR THINGS LIKE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. TOO OFTEN IT
IS WOMEN WHO ARE VICTIMS. NOT
ONLY LOSE THEIR EMPLOYMENT BUT
LOSE THE POSSIBILITY OF FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THESE NO
RE HIRE CLAUSES. THIS IS ONE OF
THAT SOMETIMES RARE INSTANCES
WHERE WERE APPLYING THIS TO
BOTH THE PUBLIC. AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SO WHAT'S GOOD
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHICH WE
OFTEN DO IS NOW ALSO GOOD FOR
US SO THAT IS ONE BENEFIT. NOW
THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS RAISED
BY A NUMBER OF YOU THAT THE
PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WOULD ALSO BE ABLE
TO USE THIS CLAUSE. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE VOTING ON.
NEVER THE BILL AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE PERPETRATORS WILL NOT
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF THIS LAW
TODAY WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
STAND SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ERICO
. ALL MEMBERS
ROAD USER TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. AS FAR AS FORTY
ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOSE
GUYS FORTY ONE NEWS SIXTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE FILE ITEM FIFTY
AB TWENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ A SINGLE A TWENTY SEVEN BY
SONY MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACKLAND
SOLID WASTE MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THIS
MEASURES BACK ON CONCURRENCE
IT'S A COMMON SENSE BILL TO
HELP US ADDRESS OUR RECYCLING
WASTE AND CLIMATE GOALS MAKING
SURE RESTAURANTS INCLUDE
BUSINESSES BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
RECYCLABLES. WASTE AND
COMPOSTABLE CERTAINLY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS HOUSE
GOING OUT AND ASK THAT AGAIN
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FORTY SIX NO
STATE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. VIOLATING FIFTY
ONE A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ A SOMETHING
ALL THIRTEEN NINETY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION. DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YES THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE IN TERMS OF THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS OF THE MEN
WAS TAKEN IN THE SENATE WERE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND
POLICY COMMITTEE ON ALL. OR ON
THE FLOOR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK I'VE- THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE- CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY THREE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ORGAN DO. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
THREE REGARDING LIVING ORGAN
DONATION. IN ITS FINAL FORM. AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
AN EMPLOYEE TO TAKE IN A AN
ADDITIONAL UNPAID LEAVE OF
ABSENCE UP TO THIRTY BUSINESS
DAYS IN A ONE YEAR PERIOD. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ORGAN DONATION.
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE WOULD
ALSO PROHIBIT INSURERS FROM
DECLINING RATING OR LIMITING
COVERAGE OF A PERSON. UNDER A
LIFE OR DISABILITY INSURANCE
POLICY SOLELY DUE TO THE STATUS
OF THE PERSON AS A LIVING ORGAN
DONATION. THIS IS A FINAL FORM
VOTE THERE WERE NO AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MLS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE BILL IN FINAL FORM
PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
AB FOURTEEN FORTY THE CLERK
WILL READ AS A LEGAL FOURTEEN
FORTY BY SELLING OVER THE BEAN
AND ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS.
IF YOU LIVE IN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
FORTY IS UP FOR A FINAL FORM
VOTE BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE
NOTE ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
ACCOMPLISHING HERE WE ARE.
FINALLY PRIORITIZE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT OVER
OIL DRILLING THIS IS IN A YEAR
WHERE WE LEARNED THAT IN THE
PAST SIXTEEN YEARS FIFTY
MILLION GALLONS OF CRUDE HAS
BEEN SPILLED IN KERN MOST
RECENTLY. ANOTHER SPILLED JUST
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS IN
KERN COUNTY. HAVING THOUSANDS
OF GALLONS OF OIL BEING DROPPED
IN POISONING IN OUR LAND. I
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE EARLIER
THIS YEAR ON THIS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CONFORMANCE ON OF
THE FINAL FORM. THANK YOU
MISTER LEVINE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
AYE AYES FORTY ONE NO SEVENTEEN
BILL PASSES IN FINAL FORM
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY SOME BY
SENATOR GLAZER IN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO RECONSIDERATION BEING
GRANTED WITH UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS IT GRANTED.
YES. ON THE BILL THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR GLAZER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MR QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR UNANIMOUSLY AGREEING FOR
RECONSIDERATION I HOPE EVERYONE
COMES IN FROM THE BREAK ROOM SO
WE CAN GET THIS OVER WITHOUT
GOING ON NOW ON CALL AGAIN.
THIS IS A BILL THAT SUPPORTED
BOTH BY THE CALIFORNIA LET
LABOR FEDERATION AND THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES. I'M GOING TO READ
FOR THE ARGUMENT THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES MADE ARE IN SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. WITHOUT ANY ACTION.
THANK YOU. LEAGUES POLICY
STATES THAT SALES TAX
AGREEMENTS INVOLVING ONLINE
RETAILS SHOULD BE PROHIBITED
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE EFFECT OF ENCOURAGING
REVENUE TO BE SHIFTED AWAY FROM
NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES AND
CONCENTRATE TO THE BENEFIT OF
ONE AGENCY WITH A PORTION READ
DEAR REBATED TO A RETAILER WITH
THE INCREASING VOLUME OF
INTERNET SALES A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SALES TAX REVENUE CAN
BE CONCENTRATING RETAILERS
WAREHOUSE. SALES OFFICE OR FOR
FILM AND SANDERS WHICH WHICH
MAKES LOCATING THESE FACILITIES
AN ENTICING PROSPECT FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES AGREEMENT THAT
BENEFITS ONE AGENCY BY SHIFTING
THE POINT OF SALE CAN COME TO
THE FISCAL HARM OF MANY OTHERS
SO AGAIN I'M SPEAKING ABOUT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CITIES IN THIS
STATE. OUR AND WE WANT TO
PREVENT RIGHT NOW USED TO THE
BOTTOM WE'RE BILLIONS ARE GIVEN
AWAY TO CORPORATIONS WHEN OTHER
CITIES ARE DEPRIVED OF THAT
REVENUE. I ASKED THE ARRIVE OF.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK. IN
ADDITION TO. MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE. AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF A
THE INLAND EMPIRE WE'RE MANY OF
THE WAREHOUSES ARE. LOCATED I
SEE EVERY DAY THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THEM. AND SO TO
CHANGE. WHERE OR WHO HAS THE.
ABILITY TO GAIN OF FROM
REVENUES IS IT WOULD BE VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR AREA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DENNIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS LIKE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION I JOIN WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE.
TEN PERCENT. OF THE NATION'S
WAREHOUSES ARE LOCATED AND IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO USE THE
BENEFIT OF THE TAX BASE. TO FIX
OUR ROADS TO DO WHATEVER NEEDS
TO BE DARK E. THEN ARE CAN MEET
THEIR ABSOLUTELY AT A
DISADVANTAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MISS REST
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I DO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE A LEGAL
CITIES BELIEVES THIS IS
ACTUALLY A GOOD DEAL. AND THIS
DOES NOT AND I UNDERLYING THAT
THIS DOES NOT STATE THAT THIS
IS GOING TO UNRAVEL IN THE
EXISTING DEAL. WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO LOOK AT A LONG TERM
SOLUTION THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT BUT THIS WILL HELP US FROM
GETTING WORSE THAN THAN WHAT IT
ALREADY IS THERE ARE STREETS
AND SIDEWALKS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT OTHER
CITIES THAT MAY NOT HAVE THOSE
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES. THAT
HAVE THE SAME NEEDS SO WITH
THAT A LONG TERM SOLUTION IS
NEEDED BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN LEAST STOP THE
BLEEDING AND HELP US BY
SOMETIME TO WE GET TO THAT LONG
TERM. SOLUTION. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON AMERICA'S RIGHT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL YOU KNOW
I'M LOOKING AT THE ANNOUNCES
HIS BILL IS SUPPORTED NOT ONLY
BY THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA CITIES
BUT ALSO THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. THEY ARE IS A
SUPPORTER BY BOTH THE CITIES
AND THE LABOR FEDERATION
BECAUSE THIS IS GOOD POLICY I
MEAN IF IT'S A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM OR CITIES I MEAN I
RESPECT I RESPECT TO OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE FIGHTING
FOR THE JOBS IN YOUR DISTRICTS
BUT FROM A STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE I MEAN IF THERE
EVER RACE INTO THE BOTTOM TO
TRY TO. COMPETE ONE CITY OF
VERSES ANOTHER TO TRY TO
ATTRACT THE JOBS YOUR CITIES
IT'S A IT AGAIN LIKE A MISTER
DOCTOR QUIRK INDICATE IT'S A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM IS BAD
POLICY YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE ENTIRE STATE IS
THAT WE. BUT WE STOP THIS RACE
TO THE BOTTOM I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. MISTER
MURATSUCHI MISTER PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AGAIN MEMBERS ARE RISE
IN OPPOSITION. THIS IS GOING TO
PARTICULARLY SAT BACK. UP MANY
OF THE CITIES IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE CITY
OF FRESNO. THESE ARE TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AND THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR
EVERYBODY. AND BECAUSE IN A
COMPETITION FOR IDEAS A
COMPETITION FOR OPPORTUNITY
THERE WILL BE SOME WHO WILL
LOSE AND SOME WHO WILL WIN. THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE IS PLACES LIKE
FRESNO. THAT HAVE HAD DOUBLE
DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT FOR A LONG
TIME. WE ARE NOW SEEING THAT
DOUBLE DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT
SUBSTANTIALLY IN SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED. WE HAVE BEEN ASKED
REPEATEDLY STATE WIDE PLEASE
DIVERSIFY YOUR ECONOMY. WHEN WE
DIVERSIFY OUR ECONOMY WE ARE
NOW LOOKING AT ESSENTIALLY A
PENALTY GOING FORWARD THOUSANDS
OF NEW JOBS HAVE BEEN CREATED.
WE HAVE. COMPANIES OF
SIGNIFICANT STATURE. WITH HUGE
NAME IDENTIFICATION. IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THAT SAYS SOMETHING
ABOUT HOW MUCH WE WELCOME THOSE
BUSINESSES. AND WHY FRESNO WHAT
TO BE LOOKED AT FOR NOT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY CITY. PLEASE DON'T
ON RAVEL A GOOD POLICY THAT HAS
BEEN USED VERY SUCCESSFULLY BY
SOME OF THE CITY'S MOST
IMPACTED BY ON EMPLOYMENT WE'RE
DIGGING OURSELVES OUT OF THAT
DOUBLE DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT THANK
GOODNESS AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
SO PLEASE DON'T ON WIND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST TO OTHER MUNICIPALITIES
AND OTHERS ROLL YOUR SLEEVES UP.
COMPETE AND YOU PROBABLY WILL
WIN YOUR SHARE AND SO I'M
ASKING PLEASE ON BEHALF OF
THOSE WORKING IN THESE JOBS IN
OUR AREAS AND WILL BE WORKING
IN ON THEM IN FUTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AGAIN I'M ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER PATTERSON. SEE IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY
CLOSE. SO IF WE PASS THIS BILL.
A CITY COULD STILL SAY WELL
WE'LL GIVE YOU A BREAK ON REAL
ESTATE TAX WILL GIVE YOU A
BREAK ON ANOTHER TAX WHAT THEY
CAN'T DO. IS TAKE AWAY TAX FROM
OTHER CITIES WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IT'S UNFAIR AND
ALSO UNNECESSARY THE REASON YOU
HAVE THESE WAREHOUSES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IS VERY
SIMPLE IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO
HAVE A WAREHOUSE. THEY THEN
COME IN THE BIG COMPANIES COME
IN AND THEY SAY WILL YOU GIVE
US A BREAK AND SALES TAX WILL
YOU GIVE US A BREAK AND SALES
TAX FINALLY ONE CITY DECIDES TO
GIVE THEM A BREAK AND THEY GO
THERE THAT'S UNFAIR COMPETITION
AND THAT'S ALSO DEPRIVING. OF
THE CITIES OF THEIR SALES TAX
REVENUE IF WE ARE ALL ON A
LIVING PLAYING FIELD IF YOU ALL
HAVE OTHER WAYS TO INDUCE
PEOPLE YOU STILL HAVE THE TOOLS
YOU NEED. SO PLEASE THIS IS A
MATTER OF FAIRNESS TO ALL THE
CITIES THAT'S WHY THE LEAGUE
SUPPORTS IT AND ALSO WHY THE
LABOR FEDERATION SUPPORTS IT I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR QUIRK THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL LOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE
THIS MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE
ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO THROUGH SIXTY SIX. PASS AND
RETAIN
. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN. THIS
IS A SEE A SIX BY MR MCCARTY
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
PRESENT ACA SIX WHICH WOULD
PLACE ON THE BALLOT A MEASURE
TO RESTORE VOTING RIGHTS FOR
THOSE FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
UNITED STATES IS THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO
DEMOCRACY BUT VOTING HASN'T
ALWAYS BEEN THAT WAY FROM OUR
JIM CROW RACIALLY BASED POLL
TAXES TO EXCLUDING WOMEN TO
VOTE WE'VE HAD TO FIGHT FOR
VOTING JUSTICE FOR A LONG TIME.
IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE PROBABLY
TALK ABOUT OUR PROGRESSIVE
IDEALS AND WE'VE EXPANDED
VOTING RIGHTS BUT IN THIS ISSUE
WHERE FRANKLY BEHIND MANY
STATES ACROSS OUR NATION. WE
HALF THE STATES IN OUR COUNTRY
ARE AHEAD OF US IN REGARDS
LIVING THOSE PEOPLE WITH
CONVICTIONS ON PAROLE VOTES
THIS ISN'T A RED STATE OR BLUE
STATE ISSUE IT'S A QUESTION
ABOUT OUR VALUES AND SOUNDS.
LIKE POLICY THAT'S WHY STATES
LIKE NEVADA MAIN UTAH LOUISIANA
ARE LEADING THE WAY THE LAST
FEW MONTHS FLORIDA COLORADO AND
NEVADA HAVE ALSO JOINED THE
EFFORTS. AND WHY HAVE RED
STATES AND CONSERVATIVES LIKE
NEWT GINGRICH GROVER NORQUIST.
AND THE COOK BROTHERS. ACTUALLY
OF COURSE ONE OF RECENTLY
PASSED WHY HAVE THEY JOINED THE
ACLU AND THE FREE THE VOTE
COALITION TO SUPPORT THIS
ISSUE. BECAUSE IT'S MORALLY
RIGHT ABOUT IT CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT ARE VOTING BUT ALSO IT
SOUNDS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT OUR PAROLE
AND PROBATION OFFICERS WHO WERE
ON THE FRONT LINES WHEN IT
COMES TO WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE. AND THEY
I THINK SUMMIT UP VERY SUS
THINK WAY. STATING THAT GIVING
PEOPLE RETURNING HOME FROM
PRISON AXE TO SIT TO CIVIC
PARTICIPATION IS ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS. TO ASSURE
THEIR SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION
BACK IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
FURTHER AD BLOCKING PEOPLE ON
PAROLE FROM VOTING MEANS OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE WORKING
PAYING TAXES RAISING THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE STATE. ARE
DEPRIVED OF THE VISIT ABILITY
TO HAVE A SAY IN THE POLICIES
AND ISSUES OF OUR DAY. SO AGAIN
YOU ASKED THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS THE MOST
ARE PEARL OFFICERS AND
PROBATION OFFICERS THEY SAY
THIS IS SOUND PUBLIC POLICY.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT VOTING
RIGHTS IS ABOUT REINTEGRATION
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. THERE BEEN
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT EXEMPTING
CERTAIN INDIVIDUAL CERTAIN
OFFENDERS FROM VOTING AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT'S REALLY A
DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE YOU CAN BE
AN OFFENDER. ON PROBATION WITH
A CERTAIN OFFENSE AND VOTE YOU
CAN HAVE A CERTAIN OFFENSE THAT
WE DEEMED. VERY TROUBLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE WHO OUR SERVE THEIR
THEIR PAROLE TERM CAN VOTE. SO
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE ACROSS THE BOARD
FAIRNESS IN VOTING RIGHTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEN LASTLY I HAVE AN OPINION
ON THIS I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE A SEPARATE OPINION ON THIS
THIS IS GONNA ASK THIS IS
ASKING US TO MAKE THAT CHOICE
IS ASKING US. TO ASK THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO WEIGH IN THIS ISSUE WHY ASK
THE VOTERS BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THE ELECTORATE LOCKED
IN WHO WAS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE WE
CAN ONLY MAKE THIS CHANGE BY
GOING TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THINGS
REGARDING MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND I HAVE
TO COMMEND THE GENTLEMAN FROM
SACRAMENTO THIS IS PROBABLY THE
FIRST TIME HE'S EVER CITED NEWT
GINGRICH AND THE COOK BROTHERS.
TO GET SUPPORT FOR A BILL. BUT
ALL THAT ASIDE YOU KNOW WE HAD
THIS BILL IN THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AND THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS. SENDS ON PAROLE HAVE
NOT FINISH THEIR SENTENCE. I'VE
BEEN RELEASED EARLY AND THEY'VE
BEEN RELEASED ON CONDITIONS ON
PAROLE AND THEIR REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO MEET TO SHOW
THAT YES THEY CAN BE THAT THEY
ARE RE INTEGRATED BACK INTO
SOCIETY. AND LET'S NOT FORGET.
THESE PERSONS HAVE CREATED VERY
HAVE COMMITTED VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES MURDERS. RAPES. THESE
ARE THINGS THAT. CHANGE
PEOPLE'S LIVES FOR EVER PEOPLE
THAT WERE MURDERED THEY'LL
NEVER GET TO VOTE AGAIN. NO
NEVER GET TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AGAIN. PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN RAPED THEIR LIVES ARE
CHANGED FOR EVER. SO NO THEY
HAVEN'T COMPLETED THEIR
PENNANTS THEY HAVEN'T COMPLETED.
THEIR SENTENCE WHEN THEY'RE ON
PRO ONCE THEY'RE OFF PAROLE WE
ALLOW THEM TO VOTE. THAT'S FAIR.
THAT IS MORE THAN FAIR. AND WE
SHOULD CONSIDER THAT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. THIS
ISSUE. I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO THINK ABOUT.
YES YOU KNOW OUR OUR DEMOCRACY
ONCE. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'VE
COMMITTED CRIMES AGAINST OTHER
PEOPLE CERTAIN RIGHTS GET TAKEN
AWAY. AND I DOUBT THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
WOULD BE ADVOCATING THAT
PAROLEES GET THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS RESTORED.
FATHER ON PAROLE WHAT HE AND
TRUST THEM WITH OWNING A
POSSESSING A FIREARM AS THEIR
REQUIRE AS THEY HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DO
UNDER THE SECOND AMENDMENT. BUT
HE WANTS TO RESTORE THEIR
VOTING RIGHTS YOU WON'T TRUST
HIM WITH THE GUN. BUT YOU'D
LIKE TO ENTRUST THEM WITH OUR
DEMOCRACY. NOW LOOK THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE. WHO HAVE
COMMITTED CRIMES HAVE DONE
THEIR PENNANTS AND THEY ARE
WORKING TO BE REHABILITATED
BACK AND TO SOCIETY I BELIEVE.
M. REPENTANCE I BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE CHANGE THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE RE REHABILITATED.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T FACE CONSEQUENCES.
FOR WHAT THEY HAVE DONE. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE SHOULD
FORGET ABOUT THEIR VICTIMS. AND
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM. IN THAT
YES ONCE THAT SENDS IS COMPLETE
THEN YES THEY SHOULD FULLY BE
PARTICIPATING THEIR DEMOCRACY
AND THEY DO. SO I THINK IT'S A
PRETTY SIMPLE CHOICE FOR US
TODAY THERE'S REALLY NOTHING
WRONG WITH CURRENT LAW AND WE
SHOULD KEEP IT THAT WAY WE
DON'T NEED TO CHANGE IT THANK
YOU AVERAGE REAR NO VOTE. ON
THIS A CA. MISS KOREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO BE A
CO AUTHOR OF A CA SIX AN
AMENDMENT THAT HONORS THE
DIGNITY OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED NEARLY
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ON PEARL
IN CALIFORNIA ARE WORKING
PAYING TAXES AND POSITIVELY
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER TOO OFTEN THESE
RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE WERE
INCARCERATED EXTEND BEYOND
THEIR TIME SERVED MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY WHO HAVE PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY SHOULD
NOT BE PREVENTING FROM
EXERCISING THIS VERY
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. WE WANT
OPPORTUNITY REDEMPTION SAFETY
SUCCESS NOT OBSTACLES VOTING IS
THE FOUNDATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY
AND CURRENTLY PAROLEES ARE
UNABLE TO VOTE AT ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT ACA SIX ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA TO RESTORE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE TO NEARLY FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS ROOTED IN THE
PRINCIPLE THAT EVERY SINGLE
VOICE MATTERS AND PROMOTING
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AKES OUR
COMMUNITY STRONGER IT IS A LONG
OVERDUE THAT CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME ARE
PROVIDED A PATHWAY TO FULL
INTEGRATION BACK INTO SOCIETY
AND WHAT WE ARE ASKING IS THAT
WE ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
TO MAKE THIS DECISION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. NAME IS CARRILLO MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE AS A CO AUTHOR IN FULL
SUPPORT OF A CA SIX AS THE
AUTHORS STATED. IT IS NOT
SIMPLY JUST THE MORALLY RIGHT
THING TO DO BUT IT IS. GOOD FOR
OUR COMMUNITY IT IS WHAT WILL
MAKE US SAFER AS A COMMUNITY
AND WE'RE PAYING WE'RE PLAYING
CATCH UP HERE. BUT A LOT OF
OTHER STATES WE KNOW THAT WHEN
WE LOWER RECIDIVISM THAT IS
GOOD FOR A COMMUNITIES WE KNOW
THOSE THAT ARE BE INTEGRATED
INTO OUR COMMUNITY AND BOATING
HAS BEEN SHOWN AS A WAY TO BE.
RE INTEGRATED INTO OUR
COMMUNITY THE LIKELIHOOD OF
THEM COMMITTING A CRIME AGAIN
IS REDUCE AND THAT'S WHY THERE
IS SUPPORT FROM THOSE THAT HAVE
THE MISSION OF MONITORING THOSE
THAT ARE RELEASED. BUT TO GIVE
THEM THE RIGHT TO VOTE. ALSO
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
DOUBLE CHECKED WITH SOME OF MY
FORMER. COLLEAGUES IN THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE. THEY
DOES THAT ARE EITHER FOUND
GUILTY OR PLEAD GUILTY ARE NOT
INFORMED OF THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE GIVING UP. THEIR RIGHT
TO VOTE. AND SO IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE TAKING THIS RIGHT AWAY AND
YOU'RE NOT INFORMING ONE. ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE PURPOSE OF
DOING IT OTHER THAN TAKING
AWAY. THEIR ABILITY TO EXERCISE
THEIR VOICE IN THEIR DEMOCRACY.
ULTIMATELY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
PAROLE THE GOOD A PAROLE. AND
THE PURPOSE OF PRO THE GOAL OF
PRO IS NOT EARLY SHOULD NOT BE
PUNISHMENT. IT IS ABOUT
REINTEGRATION. INTO SOCIETY.
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF
MEASURES THAT DEAL WITH THE
ABILITY TO FURTHER PUNISH IF
SOMEONE FAILS ON PAROLE BUT BY
TAKING AWAY THE RIGHT TO VOTER
ALLOWING THE RIGHT TO VOTE
REALLY DOESN'T SPEAK. TO THE
GOAL OF PAROLE FRANKLY ALLOWING
FOR REINTEGRATION SHOULD ALLOW
YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN YOUR
DEMOCRACY. AND ULTIMATELY LET'S
THINK ABOUT THE FOUNDATION OF
Y. PAROLEES ARE THOSE THAT HAVE
CONVICTIONS ON THE RECORD OR
THOSE. THAT HAVE TROUBLED PASS
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH. ARE
TAKEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
TAKEN AWAY THAT FOUNDATION IS
IN SLAVERY AND IN POST
RECONSTRUCTION LAWS THAT SOON
AFTER SLAVERY THE REALITY IS
THAT THAT IS WHEN WE STARTED
SEEING LAWS THAT SAID IF YOU'RE
ON PAROLE OR IF YOU HAVE
CONVICTIONS. BUT YOU SHOULD NOT
BUILD A VOTE AND WE KNOW QUITE
CLEARLY. UP THROUGH OUR HISTORY
THAT THOSE THAT HAD BEEN
INTENSELY CAUGHT UP IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE
PREDOMINANTLY PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND POOR PEOPLE TAKING WITH THE
RIGHT TO VOTE WAS QUITE
INTENTIONALLY DONE NOT TO
PUNISH BUT TO TAKE THEIR VOICE
AWAY FROM THEIR DEMOCRACY. AND
TO ALLOW FOR AN ELECTORATE THAT
DOES NOT REPRESENT OUR
COMMUNITY SO I URGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO I'LL GO OUT THE
VOTERS TO DECIDE. IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO JOIN SO MANY OTHER
STATES IN ALLOWING PAROLEES THE
RIGHT TO VOTE THANK YOU. THINGS
KALRA MISSED. YOUR RECORD THIS
IS SPEAKER COLLEAGUES. I AM A
LAW AND ORDER PERSON
CONSERVATIVE IF I WAS A JUDGE
IDEA HANG AND JUDGE. NOW I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH DIFFERENT
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS FOR
CONVICTS ONE OF MY FAVORITES IN
MY DISTRICT IS RISE UP. MY.
CALLING FROM CARSON WORKS WITH
HOME BOYS ANDERS OF AT MY LAST
COUNT SEVENTEEN OTHER RE HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS SOLD MY RISE UP.
PROVIDES TRAINING. HIGH LEVEL
COMPUTER MACHINERY. THEY BECOME
MACHINISTS OVER AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH PERIOD NOW THESE PEOPLE.
HAVE SERVE FORTY YEARS THIRTY
YEARS IN PRISON. AND. THEY WERE
IN A HOPELESS SITUATION. THESE
PROGRAMS RESTORE HOPE. I COULD
SEE IT NOW RISE. IT IS AN
ATTITUDE CHANGE FOR MAY. ONE OF
THE TENETS OF CHRISTIANITY IS
THE FORGIVENESS. ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. WHAT HAPPENS IS. THESE
PEOPLE NOW HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE
JOB. THEY'RE BEING TRAINED AND
IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS THEY CAN GET
A THIRTY DOLLAR AN HOUR JOB
THIRTY FIVE DOLLAR AN HOUR JOB.
THEY SUFFER FROM PTSD AND ALL
THE MELODIES OF BEING A
LIFETIME IN PRISON. SO I
SUPPORT ACA'S SIX BECAUSE IT'S
ANOTHER FUNDAMENTAL RESTORATION
OF WHOLE. YOU CAN'T BELIEVE HOW
MUCH IT MEANS TO A LIFE FOR.
NOT TO I'M WORKING WITH RIGHT
NOW. TO BE ABLE TO VOTE. AND
WORK ON BECOMING A CITIZEN NOW
IF THEY MESS IT UP. GO BACK TO
PRISON GO OF PAROLE THEY CAN'T
VOTE. SO I'M A GAMBLING MAN I'M
WILLING TO PLACE MY CHIPS. ON A
CA SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MULTIPLE METAPHORS THERE MR
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SO EITHER
BELIEVE IN REHABILITATION WE
DON'T. WE BELIEVE IN THE IN ALL
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM OR WE DON'T
CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS PEOPLE
WHO ARE OUT ON PAROLE OUT ON
PROBATION ARE THERE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE EARNED THE TRUST OF
THE SYSTEM. TO COME BACK INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND PARTICIPATE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT AND SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN
ELECTIONS IF YOU'RE THAT AFRAID
OF ASKING THE VOTERS THIS
QUESTION OR IF YOU ARE THAT
AFRAID. OF HAVING PEOPLE VOTES.
WHO YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH ALL
RIGHT. THEN YOU SHOULD BE
AFRAID ENOUGH TO NOT SUPPORT
THIS IF YOU BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION AND IF YOU
BELIEVE IN MAKING SURE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATES TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE WE HAVE TO PUT
THIS ON THE BALLOT WE HAVE TO
BRING CALIFORNIA UP WITH ALL
THESE OTHER STATES. AND LET'S
GIVE PEOPLE A REAL CHANCE TO BE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND HAVE
THEIR VOICES HEARD I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF A CA SIX.
FAMOUS DAMAGE MURATSUCHI YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF A CA SIX. I'M
LOOKING AT THE- MY NOTES HERE
AND ACCORDING TO A CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT CASE. PEOPLE
VERSUS KNUCKLES PAROLE IS
LEGALLY NOT PART OF A PRISON
TERM. THIS IS A SUPERVISED RE
ENTRY PERIOD AFTER COMPLETION
OF A PRISON TERM SO. YOU KNOW.
QUITE HONESTLY I'M USUALLY NOT
RISING IN SUPPORT OF CRIME
BILLS THAT COME FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO. BUT
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A GOOD
PUBLIC SAFETY BILL. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT. GIVING A STAKE IN
THE COMMUNITY. BY EXERCISING
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
REHABILITATION AND CUTTING DOWN
ON THE RECIDIVISM. ALL OF
CRIMINALS THAT IS WHY IF YOU
LOOK ON THE BILL ANALYSIS ALL
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS
ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL. SO
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY REASONS. AND
ALSO I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS NOT.
NO I DON'T SEE THIS IS GIVING A
RIGHT. CRIMINALS BUT I SEE THIS
IS GIVING A RESPONSIBILITY. A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENGAGE IN
SOCIETY A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENGAGE. AND FOR THAT REASON I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU
MISS MURATSUCHI MINS
KAMLAGER-DOVE. YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU I AT STAND IN JOYFUL
SHOCK WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SOUTH BAY. JOINING ARMS
WITH US IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL I AM A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
A CA SIX WHICH WILL RESTORE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE TO PEOPLE ON
PAROLE YOU KNOW. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE ISSUES
THERE'S A LOT OF JUDGMENT IN
THE COMMENTS THAT WE MAKE BUT
REAL TALK. PAROLEES ARE OUR
NEIGHBORS THEY ARE OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS THEY ARE COLLEAGUES
THEY ARE NOT THE BOOGIE MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE SHADOWS. THEY HAVE
BEEN RELEASED FROM PRISON
BECAUSE THEY ARE NO LONGER
CONSIDERED A THREAT TO OUR
SOCIETY. AND YET WE'VE DECIDED
THAT THEY ARE TOO DANGEROUS TO
RE EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO
VOTE. THAT IS ABSURD. THIS
AMENDMENT IS ABOUT RE
ENFRANCHISEMENT. YOU GET THE
RIGHT TO VOTE WHEN YOU ARE
EIGHTEEN YOU LOSE IT WHEN YOU
ARE INCARCERATED TEMPORARILY.
WE'RE SAYING IT SHOULDN'T BE
FOR EVER. YOU COME OUT WITH
HIGH EXPECTATIONS OF PAYING
TAXES OF BEING INTEGRAL TO THE
ECONOMIC AND THE SOCIAL FABRIC
OF OUR SOCIETY AND YET WE TELL
YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE A VOICE.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE. AND YOU
WILL NEVER GET THE KINDS OF LOW
RECIDIVISM RATES AND
INTEGRATION THAT YOU WANT IF
YOU CONTINUE TO MARGINALIZE
PEOPLE AND KEEP THEM IN THE
SHADOWS BECAUSE OF FEAR AND
JUDGMENT. FOURTEEN OTHER STATES
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA HAVE STEPPED UP TO THE
PLATE. CALIFORNIA IT IS OUR
TIME. WE KNOW THAT THIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR WE KNOW THAT IT
WOMEN THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION IN OUR PRISONS. SO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT JUSTICE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RIGHT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT REHABILITATION. LET'S NOT
TALK ABOUT IT IN FALSE TERMS.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO WHO WE CLAIM TO
BE AS AMERICANS. AND IF YOU ARE
ON PAROLE. YOU SHOULD HAVE THAT
RIGHT. I URGENT I VOTE ON A CA
SIX. THINGS CAN LEARN OF MS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND JOHN I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BUT I HAVE A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. IT ARE THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON THIS BILL
RELATING TO WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE IN OTHER WORDS
DOES IT ANY RESTRICTIONS
RELATING TO THE ANY PARTICULAR
CRIME ARE SOME EXCLUDED OR IS
IT EVERYONE THAT HE WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE. THIS MCCARTY SHARE IT
WOULD RELATE TO ANYBODY WHO IS
PEARL CURRENTLY WHEN YOUR
PAROLE SENTENCE IS DONE YOU CAN
VOTE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY COUNTY
GIRL THINGS I'M SINCE IN THIS
MEASURE OKAY THANK YOU. SO I
GUESS WE SHOULD TALK THEN ABOUT
THE ELIGIBILITY AND THOSE WHO
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE. SO I
TALKED TO MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOLKS FROM THREE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES ASK FOR SOME EXAMPLES.
ALL WHO ARE ON PAROLE HAVE BEEN
RE ARRESTED THESE ARE ALL
WITHIN A YEAR BY THE WAY BEING
PAROLED. THE FIRST ONE IS A
CONVICTED RAPIST. GOT PAROLED
AND THEN WHILE HE WAS OUT ON
PAROLE DECIDED HE WAS GOING TO
THROW ACID ON PEOPLE'S FACES IN
ORDER TO ROB THEM. HE WOULD GET
TO VOTE. THE SECOND ONE
CONVICTED OF ASSAULT AND
ATTEMPTED RAPE. WENT TO PRISON
GOT OUT VIOLATED PAROLE ALSO
FAILED TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER HE WOULD GET ABOUT THE
THIRD ONE WAS CONVICTED OF
CHILD MOLESTATION WAS PAROLED.
AND THEN WAS ARRESTED AGAIN FOR
FAILURE TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER HE GETS ABOUT. THE
FOURTH ONE FORCIBLE RAPE GOT
PAROLED FAILED TO REGISTER. GOT
ARRESTED AGAIN FIFTY ONE CHILD
MOLESTATION GOT ARRESTED WENT
TO PRISON GOT PAROLED AND WAS
ARRESTED AGAIN FOR HAVING CHILD
**** A FEW WEEKS AGO THERE WAS
JUST A CASE IN GARDEN GROVE I'M
SURE YOU ALL SAW THE VIDEO. AND
THE GUY WHO WENT ON A STABBING
SPREE. HE BEEN IN PRINT IN AND
OUT OF PRISON FOURTEEN TIMES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HE
WOULD GET ABOUT. SO. I'M JUST
WONDERING AT WHAT POINT WE ARE
GOING TO STOP. FOCUSING ALL OF
OUR EFFORTS ON THOSE WHO BREAK
THE LAW AND START FOCUSING ON
VICTIMS AND THEIR RIGHTS. YOU
THE AVERAGE TIME A PAROLE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THREE TO FIVE
YEARS THAT IS NOT A LOT OF TIME
TO ASK SOMEONE TO LIVE BY THE
SAME STANDARDS AT THE REST OF
US LIVE BY IT'S NOT A LOT OF
TIME. YOU GO TO PRISON FOR SOME
VERY SERIOUS CRIMES AND WHEN
YOU GET PAROLED. IT IS WITH
RESTRICTIONS YOU. THE FREEDOM
OF ASSOCIATION YOU WERE TOLD TO
STAY AWAY FROM CERTAIN PEOPLE
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT. YOU CAN'T JUST UP AND
LEAVE AND GO TO ANOTHER STATE
OR ANOTHER COUNTY. THERE ARE
RESTRICTIONS THAT'S FOR RECENT.
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM ISN'T QUITE
CONVINCED THAT YOU ARE WILLING
TO FOLLOW THE LAWS THAT
EVERYONE ELSE MUST FOLLOW. THIS
IS THE SAME FOR VOTING.
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY ARE
PAROLED AND THEY FINISH THEIR
PRO THEY GET THEIR VOTING
RIGHTS BACK ONE OF FOUR STATES
THAT ALLOW THAT THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT ONCE YOU'VE
SHOWN DID YOU ARE WILLING TO
LIVE BY THE STANDARDS IN THE
RULES OF SOCIETY IS SET. IS IT
APPROPRIATE FOR SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I MENTIONED TO BE
VOTING. FOR THEIR COUNTY
SHERIFF. IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR
THEM TO BE VOTING FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE LAWS. DO
YOU WANT TO STAND THERE AND
LOOK IN THE EYES OF THE FATHER
WHOSE DAUGHTER WAS BRUTALLY
RAPED. A PAROLED AND TELL HIM
THAT YOU THINK THE MAN THAT
HARM HIS DAUGHTER HAS THE SAME
RIGHTS. AS HE DOES TO VOTE. ARE
YOU GONNA STAND THERE AND LOOK
IN THE EYES OF THE MOTHER.
WHOSE DAUGHTER WAS SODOMIZED HE
WAS BURLY RATE TO THE POINT
WHERE SHE CAN'T HAVE CHILDREN
LOOK INTO THE EYES OF THE
MOTHER. WHOSE SON. WAS MOLESTED
OR RAPED BY SOMEONE. SO
EMOTIONALLY DAMAGE THAT HE
COMMITTED SUICIDE I CAN LOOK IN
THEIR EYES AND TELL THEM THAT
YOU THINK THAT THAT PERSON HAS
THE SAME RIGHTS SHOULD BE
TREATED THE SAME AS EVERYONE
ELSE ARE YOU KIDDING ME. THIRTY
SECONDS. NO ONE IS SAYING THAT
RIGHT ART SHOULD BE TAKEN AWAY
FOREVER. BUT IT IS ABSURD TO ME
AND LOGICAL FOR YOU TO SUGGEST
THAT SOMEHOW THESE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOT YET PAID THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS. AS A LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS IN AS OF THE BIG ITEMS
THAT THEY HARMED. I ORIGINAL
VOTE. DOCTOR WEBER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST. WHAT IS
IT NOW SEVEN YEARS I HAVE DEALT
WITH THE ISSUE OF WHO SHOULD
VOTE ON WHO SHOULD NOT VOTE AND
HOW WE HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS THAT
NEED TO EXIST. AND EVERY TIME
WE HAVE A STATION WE GO TO THE
MOST EXTREME EXAMPLES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE SYSTEM
HAS FAILED. THIS WILL NOT ONLY
TO IDENTIFY WHO ARE BUT A
DIGNIFIED THEIR NEEDS AND TO
PROPERLY DEAL WITH THEM AS THEY
SHOULD. WE CAN'T BASE OUR
POLICY ON SOME FLAWS THAT MIGHT
EXIST THAT'S NUMBER ONE IN THE
SYSTEM ITSELF. BUT WE HAVE TO
BASE IT ON THE FACT OF WHAT WE
KNOW IS RIGHT. WHAT IS JUST AND
WHAT IS GOOD FOR US. WE HAVE
TRIED EVERYTHING THIS STATE TO
BECOME HARDER AND HARDER ON
CRIMINALS. AND ONLY THINK IT IS
DONE IS MADE A HARD HARDER. AND
MADE HARD TO CRIMINALS. WE HAVE
NOT SOLVED THE PROBLEM YET. WE
SAW THAT WITH OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AS WE REDUCE THE NUMBER FROM
TEN THOUSAND IN DJJ NOW TO
SEVEN HUNDRED BY HAVING A
DIFFERENT POLICY AND A PROGRAM
TO HELP THEM IN THEIR HOMES AND
FAMILIES. SO WE START TALKING
ABOUT VOTING I'M JUST AT A
QUANDARY AS WHAT DO WE THINK
WOULD HAPPEN. IF A PERSON VOTED.
IF A PERSON THAT WE DIDN'T LIKE
VOTED. AND A LOT OF FOLKS I
DON'T LIKE WHO VOTE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THEIR MORALS THAT VOTE. AND YET
WE HAVE NOT RESTRICTED THEM
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY
THAT WAS FOUNDED ON A
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE. NO
TAXATION WITHOUT REPRESENTATION
ATTACKS PERSON IN THE STATE YOU
THEN DESERVE TO DECIDE WHO YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE WILL BE THAT IS
A FUNDAMENTAL AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES THAT I LEARNED IN
KINDERGARTEN. NO TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION. AND OUR
DESIRE TO BE PUNITIVE TO ATTACK
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PUNISH THEM ENOUGH. HAS NOT
PROVEN IN ANY WAY TO MAKE US
SAFER TO MAKE THE STATE
STRONGER AND HAS MADE OUR
BUDGET BASICALLY BLOW UP IN
TERMS OF ALL THE THINGS WE'VE
DONE THAT HAVE NOT IN ANY WAY
HELPED. CLEARLY THERE'S A NEED
FOR CHANGE. AND I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WALKS AROUND THE STATE
WORRYING ABOUT SOMEBODY VOTING.
WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN PUT MAY
HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME THAT WE
DID NOT LIKE. THAT IS GENERALLY
NOT THE CONCERN OF BOTH OF US
WALKING UP AND DOWN THE STREET
EVERY DAY THAT IF THAT PERSON
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE THEY
WOULD COMMIT MORE CRIMES WHAT
KIND OF THINKING IS THIS. THE
LOGIC IS JUST NOT BE HERE. AND
SO WHEN WE START TALKING ABOUT
FOLKS WHO GO ON IAN WHO HAVE
EARNED THE RIGHT TO BE PAROLED
KEEP THAT IN MIND. THEY'RE JUST
NOT TURNED OUT. THERE BURN THE
RIGHT FOR PAROLE. AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE OVER
HERE FROM EAST COUNTY WHO
UNDERSTANDS NOW THAT HE'S
WORKING WITH THEM THAT THESE
FOLKS HAVE SPENT YEARS TRYING
TO IMPROVE THEMSELVES AND DEAL
WITH THE ISSUES. AND COMING OUT
AND GIVING THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE THAT WE
SHOULD BE WILLING TO GIVE TO
THEM TO ALLOW THEM TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES AND TO STRENGTHEN
THEM AS THEY BECOME. A CITIZENS
AGAIN. TO BE FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN THIS SO CALLED ENTERPRISE
CALL DEMOCRACY. IT IS
INTERESTING TO ME THAT WE
CONTINUE TO GO TO THE WORST
STORIES THAT WE'VE EVER HEARD
ABOUT WHO'S A PET A FATHER
WHO'S DONE THIS AND- THAT AND
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND
YET WE STILL ARE HOLDING ON
THOSE THINGS IS IF HAVE SAID.
STORE THEIR LIVES. WOULD YOU BE
SEVEN TIMES AS WE HEARD IN THE
BIBLE OF WOULD BE SEVENTY TIMES
SEVEN YOU GIVE THEM AS MANY
TIMES NECESSARY TO BE THERE TO
GROW AND TO DEVELOP AND TO
BECOME THE CITIZEN WE WANT THEM
TO BE SO THE FACT THAT WE'VE
GOT THIS IDEA THAT WE GO TO
CREATE THESE PERFECT PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO VOTE WHEN OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE PERFECT OUR
RELATIVES AREN'T PERFECT. OUR
MINISTERS AREN'T PERFECT ALL OF
THOSE FOLKS WHO WORK IN OUR
LIVES ARE IN PERFECT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE SO I
REALLY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU
I VOTE ON THIS THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
STOP LOOKING BACK STOP DIGGING
UP ALL THINGS THAT WE CAN THROW
OUT SOME KIND OF THE GREAT
EXCITEMENT IN OUR CONSTITUENTS
THEY WERE GOING TO OBVIOUSLY
HAVE THESE RAPIST RUNNING IN
FRONT OF POLLING BOOTHS AND
VOTING. THAT THAT HONEST PEOPLE
AWAY FROM VOTING I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IMAGE WE HAVE IS WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. THOUGHT IS
THERE WILL POST. AS THEY HAVE
EARNED PAROLE. THEY'VE THEIR
DESIRE TO BE TO IMPROVE
THEMSELVES AND HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN THE THINGS THAT
THEY'VE DONE THIRTY THEN BE
WILLING TO VOTE AND BE GIVEN
THE RIGHT ONCE AGAIN TO BE
THOSE CITIZENS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT THAT BASICALLY ARE
INVOLVED IN THE GOVERNMENT AND
VOTING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU I VOTE FOR A CA SIX THAT WE
GET AWAY FROM THE FEAR TACTICS
AND ALL THE DRAMA THAT EXIST
AND REALIZE THAT THESE ARE OUR
RELATIVES OUR FRIENDS. OUR
FAMILIES OUR CHILDREN WHO NEED
A SECOND CHANCE THANKS. THANK
YOU TO WHOEVER MISTER GIBSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. RUMORS
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST
RISE AS A PROBLEM CO AUTHOR OF
ACR SIX AND THANK THE AUTHOR.
FROM SACRAMENTO FOR BRINGING
THIS A MEASURE FOR IT I WAS OFF
THE FLOOR AND ALL THE FLOOR
DIDN'T HEAR MUCH OF THEDEBATE.
OTHER THAN TO SIMPLY SAY THIS
IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO. DOCTOR
WEBER SUMMED IT UP PERFECTLY
AND I CAN ADD TO HER
ARTICULATION OF THEIRS THIS IS
ABOUT GIVING INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE PAID THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY. UNDERSCORE. THEY JUST
GET OUT THEY PAID THEIR DEBT
WHATEVER THAT DEBT MAY HAVE
BEEN. THEY PAID THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY THEY HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR PRISON SENTENCE. AND WHAT
SHOULDN'T WE BE. LOOKING AT
TRYING TO RESTORE THAT
INDIVIDUAL. TO THEIR FULLNESS
TO PARTICIPATE TO INTEGRATE
BACK INTO SOCIETY SO THAT HE
WON'T A RECIDIVIST BACK INTO A
LIFE FROM WHICH THEY CAME FROM.
OF GIVING A PERSON OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT ON
ONE READING THE PAMPHLET AND
ALSO BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION. AGAIN THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY I THINK
THIS IS A RIGHT WAY TO GO OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY TAKEN SUCH
ACTION. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
WAY SO WE SHOULD BE LEADING
THIS SPACE RIGHT NOW THANK THE
AUTHOR SACRAMENTO AND ASK FOR A
STRONG AYE VOTE. NAME SISTER
GIPSON MISTER MESS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
PHONE GOING OFF HERE ON MY DESK
SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN'T HEAR IT
BUT I AM GONNA SUPPORT THIS
TODAY ACTUALLY SUPPORTED THIS
IN COMMITTEE AND I'M GONNA
SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR TODAY
AND AS I'VE LISTENED TO SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES GIVE SPEECHES
I'VE BEEN. A LITTLE. STUNNED
REALLY BY BY SOME OF THE
BECAUSE- OUR RHETORIC I THINK
HERE IS A LITTLE OVER OVER THE
TOP. I'M FACT NOT JUST A LITTLE
OVER THE TOP I THINK REALLY.
REALLY OVER THE TOP. I DO
BELIEVE THAT VOTING. IS
INCREDIBLY SPECIAL IT IS WHAT
MAKES OUR DEMOCRACY WORK AND
WHY DO WE HAVE THIS BILL BEFORE
US TODAY IS BECAUSE IN OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION. IT SAYS
THAT IF YOU ARE ON PAROLE YOU
DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
INTERESTING CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF
FIFTY STATES. AND THERE ARE TWO
STATES IN THE U. S. THAT
ACTUALLY GIVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IF YOU ARE IN PRISON. IF YOU
ARE IN PRISON AND THERE ARE
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHER STATES
THAT ALLOW IF YOU'RE ON PAROLE
BOTH RED STATES AND BLUE STATES
IF YOU'RE ON ON PAROLE. SIMPLY
FOR US WHAT WE'RE ASKING. WHAT
THE AUTHOR IS ASKING US TO DO
TODAY IS THE PLACE. A MEASURE
ON THE BALLOT TO ASK THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA WHETHER
IT'S TIME FOR THAT WORD IS
DELETED TO ALLOW THOSE THAT ARE
ON PAROLE THE RIGHT THE RIGHT
TO VOTE IN COMMITTEE I SAID YOU
KNOW I'M NOT SURE HOW I'M GOING
TO VOTE ON THIS. WHEN I WHEN I
GO TO THE BALLOT BUT I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE QUESTION BEING
PLACED ON THE BALLOT I DO THINK
THAT WE NEED TO TONE DOWN OUR
RHETORIC WE'VE GOT A LITTLE BIT
TOO FAR A TODAY WERE ASKING THE
VOTERS A CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER A
QUESTION THAT'S BEEN TOO LONG
TO NOT BE PLACED BEFORE THEM I.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WISH MAYES.
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE
TODAY TO ALLOW THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE A DECISION
ON A CA SIX BUT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT AN INDIVIDUAL AND NOT
PEOPLE WHERE THEY OR THEM I
WANT TO TALK AGAIN ABOUT
SOMEONE I KNOW SOMEBODY WHO I
LOST THIS YEAR MY BROTHER BILLY
AND SOMETIMES A TALK ABOUT
BILLY STORY. AND AS SOME OF YOU
KNOW HE DIED LESS THAN A YEAR
AGO OCTOBER AND HE IS ONE OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD GONE
IN AND OUT OF COUNTY JAIL AND
EVEN PRISON. AND WHEN HE WOULD
COME OUT. I OFTEN WHAT ASKING
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO. AND HE
WOULD TALK ABOUT I WANT TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL. I WANT TO GET A
JOB. I WANT TO DO SOMETHING. HE
WAS FIFTY ANY SAID I HAVE A LOT
OF LIFE TO GIVE I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING AND YET SO OFTEN THE
BARRIERS THAT CAME IN FRONT OF
HIM WHETHER IT WAS GETTING TO A
PROBATION APPOINTMENT WHETHER
IT WAS HIS ADDICTION WITH
ALCOHOL WHETHER IT WAS IT. THE
VOICES HE HEARD FROM MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES FROM COMING IN
AND OUT OF BEING ON THE STREETS
HE DIDN'T MAKE IT BUT HIS HIS
STORY IS SO MANY STORIES HERE
IT'S THE STORY AS WE SAID OF
FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO STRUGGLE
AND WHEN WE SEE THOSE WHO
STRUGGLE THAT ARE RELEASED.
MANY TIMES WE ALL WANT THEM TO
IMPROVE AND YET SOME BACK STEP.
YOU YEARS AGO I WENT TO CHINO
PRISON TO. NOT ONLY THE- LOWER
SECURITY BUT THE MAXIMUM
SECURITY AND I WALKED THROUGH
THOSE GROUNDS AND I WATCHED AND
AGAIN THOSE STORIES SOME OF THE
PRISON GARDENS TOLD ME DIRECTLY
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE. COMING OUT OF THESE
PRISONS ARE GOING TO BE YOUR
NEIGHBORS. SO IT'S UP TO US TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
PREPARE THEM WELL THEY HERE ARE
IN PRISON BUT ALSO WHEN THEY
ARE RELEASED. TO INTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY IN A WAY THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND VOTING
IS A WAY THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
HAVE SOME TYPE OF HOPE. THE
WITHOUT I ASKED HER SUPPORT ON
A CA SIX. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK
SILVA. MEMBERS SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ACA MISTER MCCARTY YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER YOU KNOW WE SPENT
NEARLY AN HOUR TALKING ABOUT AN
ISSUE THAT IMPACTS OVER FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. FORTY
FIVE FIFTY THOUSAND WHY BECAUSE
THIS ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT TO
US DEMOCRACY. AND OUR STATE
COMMUNITIES GOES HAND IN HAND
AND I WOULD SAY THIS MEASURE
ENHANCES BOTH I DO WANT TO JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON IT TO ISSUES
RAISED. BY THE OPPOSITION IN MY
AND MY COLLEAGUES FROM EAST
NICHOLAS AND MENIFEE. AND WERE
TOUCHED UPON BY. OUR COLLEAGUE
BRIEFLY FROM SAN DIEGO ANSWER
BUT WHEN IT TO GO BACK ONE MORE
TIME. SO THE ISSUE. IS PAROLE I
THINK IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR AS
OUR- FRIEND IN OUR FOR FORMER
PROSECUTOR FROM LOS ANGELES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TALKED
ABOUT A SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT. PAROLE IS NOT EARLY
RELEASED YOU ARE RELEASED FROM
PRISON AND PAROLE IS THE
SUPERVISED RELEASE THROUGHOUT
THE PAROLE A DOZEN DEPARTMENT
HELP YOU RE INTEGRATE BACK INTO
SOCIETY. YOUR SENTENCES OVER.
HOWEVER SOMETIMES YOU ARE
SENTENCED TO PROBATION. YOU
KNOW THEY GET TO DO. THEY GET
TO VOTE. SO WE HAD TO SAYS THAT
ARE ARBITRARY. THEY REALLY
DON'T TAKEN OFFENSE THE REALITY
ALSO I WENT TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT YEAH AND RARE OCCASIONS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT RE OFFEND. THOSE
PEOPLE THEY DON'T GET TO VOTE.
THEY DON'T GET TO VOTE THEY'RE
GOING BACK TO PRISON SO THEY
LOSE THEIR VOTING RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE THAT RE OFFEND. DON'T
GET TO VOTE. LET'S BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR PART ABOUT THAT.
DEMOCRACY NEEDS ALL OF US. THE
TIME TESTED TRADITION. THIS IS
ABOUT CERTAINLY AND I BELIEVE
IN I KNOW PEOPLE THEIR SIDE
HAVE STRONG OPINIONS THE OTHER
WAY BUT WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
TRUSTING OUR CONSTITUENTS TRUST
IN THE VOTERS LET'S GO TO THEM
LET'S ASK THEM LET'S NOT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE WAY IN
IN TWENTY TWENTY. SB RIVAL
THANK YOU. THERE IS MCCARTY AND
WITH A COUPLE OF NARAL
HOMEOWNERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
. WHICH
MCCARTY MOVES A CALL
. MEMBERS
IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT. IS A C. R. ONE TEN BY
MISS WICKS THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TEN BY SOME REMEMBER WICKS
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE AND ABORTION
SERVICES MISS WICKS YOU'LL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. DESPITE THE LANDMARK
ROE VERSUS WADE DECISION THAT
AFFIRMED ACCESS TO SAFE AND
LEGAL ABORTION IS A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT. WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM. IS UNDER ATTACK IN
THIS COUNTRY TODAY. JUST THIS
YEAR SIXTEEN STATES FILED MOVED
OR INACTIVE A SIX WEEK ABORTION
BANS WITH MISSOURI AND GEORGIA
OPENING THE STATE TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
MISCARRIAGES. IF THE LAW GOES
INTO EFFECT IN GEORGIA WOMEN
WHO SEEK ABORTION CARE AFTER
SIX WEEKS COULD FACE LIFE IN
PRISON OR THE DEATH PENALTY.
ALABAMA ENACTED THE MOST
EXTREME ANTI ABORTION
LEGISLATION IN THE NATION BY
MAKING IT A FELONY FOR DOCTOR
TO PERFORM AN ABORTION AT ANY
TIME DURING A PREGNANCY EVEN IN
THE CASE OF RAPE OR INCEST. ARE
WE LIVING IN HANDMAID'S TALE.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
WELL THOSE WHO PUSH THESE ANTI
ABORTION LOSS CLAIM TO CARE
ABOUT LIFE MANY OF THE STATES
THAT HAVE PASSED EXTREME
ABORTION BAN LAWS HAVE AMONGST
THE HIGHEST MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY RATES IN AMERICA.
THEIR ACTIONS FURTHER ENDANGER
WOMEN'S HEALTH ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR
BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WHEN LAWS. AND RESTRICTIONS
IMPEDE THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CHOICES.
FORTUNATELY FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED TO
MAKE REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT BY
GUARANTEEING THE RIGHT TO
PRIVACY. INCLUDING ON ONE TO
HAVE OR HAVE NOT AN ABORTION.
THE ACCESS TO THE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IS THREATEN NATIONALLY
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAD
BY EXAMPLE FOR STANDING UP FOR
ACCESS TO SAFE ABORTIONS. WOMEN
AND THEIR FAMILIES ME THE
FREEDOM TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION FOR THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY DON'T
DESERVE TO PAY THE PRICE FOR A
POLITICAL RIGHT WING AGENDA.
THIS RESOLUTION IS ABOUT VALUES
IT'S A STATEMENT OF VALUES IT'S
ABOUT OUR PRINCIPLES BY
DECLARING CALIFORNIA
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE FOR
ALL ACR ONE TEN WILL REAFFIRM
OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
GUARANTEEING THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT TO AN ABORTION. AS A
LEGISLATOR AS A WOMAN. AS THE
MOTHER OF A LITTLE GIRL. I
BELIEVE IT IS OUR TIME RIGHT
NOW TO STAND UP FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT. AND I KNOW THIS
RECESSION MAKES SOME PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE. BUT THINK ABOUT
THE AND COMFORT OF THE WOMEN
LIVING IN PLACES LIKE GEORGIA
AND ALABAMA RIGHT NOW. WE CAN
BE A BEACON OF HOPE. IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW I KNOW
SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD TO MAKE
THAT DECISION. WHO HAD AN
ABORTION I THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CLINIC. IN A SAFE
AND SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT THAT
WAS MY DECISION TO MAKE AND WE
HAVE TO PROTECT THAT WE HAVE TO
SEND A MESSAGE TO THE REST REST
OF THIS COUNTRY THE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE A BEACON OF HOPE AND WE
CAN BE. THE REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AMOS WICKS MISLIM ON YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
WHEN TEN EARLIER THIS YEAR WE
COMMEMORATED THE FORTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT DECISION
IN ROE VERSUS WADE. THIS CASE
AFFIRMED EVERY WOMAN HAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS
AND WHETHER TO CONTINUE A
PREGNANCY OR OBTAIN AN ABORTION.
THE ROE VERSUS WADE DECISION
ALONG WITH THE CHRIS WILL
DECISION OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
REMAINS THE CORNERSTONE OF A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO CONTROL
THEIR REPRODUCTIVE LIVES. BUT
CHRIS HOLDEN ROW WERE A VICTORY
FOR WOMEN TO THEIR OWN BODIES.
TO OWN THEIR OWN BODIES AND LAY
THE GROUNDWORK FOR FURTHER
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE POLICIES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ONE OF TWO STATES WHERE THIS
RIGHT IS PROTECTED IN OUR
STATUTE AND OUR CONSTITUTION.
IT HIGHLIGHTS ARE SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT A
PERSON'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
DECIDE IF AND WHEN WE BECOME
APPARENT. EVEN WITH THESE
PROTECTIONS THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
ABORTION SAFELY AND LEGALLY IN
THIS COUNTRY IS IN JEOPARDY AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SUPREME COURT CAN STILL NARROW
THESE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS. THE
PROTECTIONS GRANTED BY ROE
VERSUS WADE. ARE AT THEIR
HIGHEST RISK OF BEING
OVERTURNED. ACCESS TO THE BEST
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE BASED HEALTH
CARE AND INFORMATION ARE NOW
BEING CRIMINALIZED IN OTHER
STATES. IT IS VITAL FOR
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HOME TO
NEARLY TWENTY MILLION WOMEN TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME WHEN PROVIDERS OF
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE ARE UNDER SERIOUS
UNRELENTING. ATTACK FOR
PROVIDING SAFE AND LEGAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
MEMBERS I LIKE MANY OF YOU
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT A
WOMAN'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AS
CONFIRMED INNER STATUES AND IN
OUR CONSTITUTION TO MAKE HER
OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AND
NOT TO CRIMINALIZE THEM I
REGION I VOTE ON ACR ONE TEN.
THANK YOU MS AMMAN MS RIVAS
YOUR RECORD THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M HAPPY
TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF ACR WHEN
TEN WHICH DECLARES CALIFORNIA'S
A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE
FOR ALL. THE LANDMARK DECISION
IN ROE V. WADE SOLIDIFIED THAT
WOMEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO DECIDE
WHAT THEY DO WITH THEIR BODIES
CALIFORNIA HAS CONSISTENTLY
PROVEN THAT IT WILL PROTECT
THIS DECISION AND STAND WITH
WOMEN UNFORTUNATELY OTHER
STATES DO NOT SHARE OUR VALUES
AND WE ARE ONCE AGAIN SEEN AN
ATTACK ON WOMEN'S RIGHTS. AS
STATES LIKE GEORGIA ALABAMA
LOUISIANA AND OTHERS PASS
LEGISLATION RESTRICTING A
WOMEN'S RIGHT TO GET AN
ABORTION WITHOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE WOMEN OR
DISADVANTAGE IN EVERY OTHER
PART OF THEIR LIVES THIS IS WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA
REAFFIRMS THAT IT STANDS WITH
WOMEN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK. I
ON ACR ONE TEN THANK YOU. NAME
IS RIVAS MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. SO THIS YEAR MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLS
RESTRICTING ABORTION HAVE BEEN
FILED IN FORTY ONE STATES. THIS
IS TWENTY NINETEEN PEOPLE FORTY
SIX YEARS SINCE ROE V. WADE YET
WE'RE- STATE POLITICIANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY STILL PUSHING AN
AGGRESSIVE ANTI ABORTION
AGENDA. THAT SEEKS TO DO ONE
THING TO BAN ABORTION OUT
RIGHT. OPPOSED ROE FUTURE IS
NEARING AT A VERY RAPID PACE.
WITHOUT POLICIES THAT PROTECT
AND EXPAND ACCESS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOMEN OF REPRODUCTIVE
AGE COULD LOSE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IF ROE IS OVERTURNED
OR SEVERELY RESTRICTED. I'LL
SAY THAT AGAIN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOMEN I AM SURE THAT WE
KNOW SOME OF THOSE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOMEN WE MAY BE SOME OF
THOSE TWENTY FIVE MILLION WOMEN.
I AM PROUD TO SERVE ON THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
BOARD AND PROUD TO SERVE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
CONSISTENTLY TAKES STEPS TO
EXPAND NOT TO BAN. ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE. WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY AND AN
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
PATIENTS STILL ACCESS HEALTH
CARE NO MATTER WHAT. ACR ONE
TEN CLARIFIES THAT CALIFORNIA
IS NOT STEPPING BACK WHEN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AN
ACCESS IS UNDER GRAVE THREAT
BUT THAT WE'RE STEPPING UP TO
REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
GUARANTEE THE RIGHT TO ABORTION
FOR WOMEN AND PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS. BECAUSE ABORTION
IS HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH CARE
IS A HUMAN RIGHT. I WANT TO
ALSO ADD. THAT YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT IF YOU BAN IT THAT
PEOPLE WON'T HAVE IT. THAT'S
NOT TRUE HISTORY HAS SHOWN THAT
THAT'S NOT TRUE. DO YOU WANT TO
HAVE SAFE ACCESSIBLE ACCESS. DO
YOU WANT TO HAVE DANGEROUS
RISKY FATAL ABORTIONS HAPPENING
TO SOME OF THOSE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOMEN THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE MAY BE. I SAID IT BEFORE. I
AM A WOMAN. LET ME MAKE MY OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT MY HEALTH CARE
GOVERNMENT STAY OUT OF MY ****
I URGE A YES ON A C. R. ONE TEN.
THANK YOU IS KAMLAGER-DOVE MR
GLORIA. MISS GLORIA RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TEN
DECLARING CALIFORNIA AS A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM THE STATE
FOR ALL. YEAH AS A GAY MAN I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULT
JOURNEY TO A QUALITY IN EVERY
SENSE OF THE WORD CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT. NOTHING NOTHING IN
OUR HISTORIC STRUGGLE AS LGBT
Q. AMERICANS SEEMS TO COMPARE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN. AND THEIR ONGOING
EFFORTS TO TRY CONTROL WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THEIR OWN BODIES
IN WITH THEIR OWN HEALTHCARE.
IT'S INCREDIBLE TO ME THEY WERE
STILL HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
IN TWENTY NINETEEN IN FACT IT'S
TRULY UNBELIEVABLE BUT YET HERE
WE ARE. WHAT'S WORSE I'M MORE
CONVERSATION ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE. IN LIGHT OF
THE REPEATED ATTACKS ON A
WOMAN'S BODY BY EMILY MOSTLY
MALE POLITICIANS. YOUR CALL THE
COMMEMORATION OF OUR FORTY
SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE V.
WADE EARLY THIS YEAR. I
DISCUSSED THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING BY UNITED STATES
SENATOR COMMA HARRIS NOW
JUDICIAL CONFIRMATION HEARING
SHE ASKED. THINK OF ANY LAWS
THAT GIVE THE GOVERNMENT THE
POWER. TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
A MALE BODY. THE RESPONSE AS
MANY OF YOU MAY RECALL. I'M NOT
THINKING OF ANY RIGHT NOW. SOME
OF MY HETEROSEXUAL PEERS MAY BE
ABLE TO DONATE BLOOD I STILL
CáC THàNH. I CAN STILL
UNEQUIVOCALLY BECAUSE I'M A MAN
CHOOSE TO TAKE CARE OF MY
HEALTH IN ANY WAY THAT I WISH
AT ANY PHASE OF MY LIFE. AND I
BILL I'M ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
INDEPENDENT A SCISSION MAKING
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF MY SEX. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE SAFEGUARD
THE ABILITIES OF THE RIGHTS
UNDER ROE V. WADE THOSE WITH
THOSE ARE PROVIDED TO WOMEN
BECAUSE THEY ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE. AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR LGBT Q.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ABLE TO
CONCEDE. RESEARCH HAS
IDENTIFIED HIGHER SEXUAL
ACTIVITY RATES AND I'M RATES OF
PREGNANCY AMONG LGBT Q. U. AS
COMPARED TO THEIR HETEROSEXUAL
PEERS. AND WHILE WILL BE MADE
MADE ONLY HAD CISGENDER WOMEN
IN MIND WHEN IT WAS DECIDED
OVER FIFTY YEARS FIFTY YEARS
AGO. THAT COURT DECISIONS AT
THE RIGHT PRICE IN FOR IT
ABBOTT SEEN RIGHTS OF SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE TRANSGENDER
POPULATIONS IN OUR LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY. I CAN GO ON BUT IT'S
NOTNECESSARY BUT SHOULD BE A
NO BRAINER MY COLLEAGUES I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR ONE
TEN. THERE WAS GLORIA MS PARA
QUE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE IS THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE TEN. IF YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES ALREADY
TODAY ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
UNDER ATTACK ACROSS THE NATION.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON
HAS WAGED A WAR ON WOMEN'S
RIGHT TO REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES SAID THESE ARE OUR
BODIES AND WE SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT TO CONTROL. MINISTRATIONS
USE OF THE GAG RULE ON TITLE
TEN FUNDING IS THE MOST RECENT
EFFORTS TO UNDERMINE WOMEN'S
RIGHT TO ACCESS COMPREHENSIVE.
HIGH QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
BIRTH CONTROL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES. BUT THIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETS
LOWER INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
WOMEN OF COLOR RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WILL LOSE ACCESS
TO THE COMPREHENSIVE CARE THAT
PREVENTS THEM. FROM GETTING
CANCER AND OTHER DIRE
CONSEQUENCES. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE UNDERSTAND
ABORTION IS HEALTH CARE AND
ACCESS TO IT IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
WE HAS A STAKE IN IN YOU TO
MAKE STRIDES TO DELIVER EXPAND
AND INVEST IN SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING SAFE ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE. INCLUDING THE
INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE THIS BODY AND OUR STATE TO
PUT INTO THE BUDGET. WELL THE
NATIONAL ATTACK ON WOMEN'S
RIGHT TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IS
AT THE FOREFRONT OF OUR MINDS
WE MUST ALSO REMEMBER IT IS NOT
THE ONLY PROBLEM THAT WE FACE
IN THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SPACE. CALIFORNIA PENSIONS AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
FACING THE CONSEQUENCES WELL.
ADEQUATE STAFFING FUNDING
ACCESSIBILITY ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. I
SOARING STI EPIDEMIC. PATIENT
SAFETY. CONSUMER FRAUD AND AN
UNACCEPTABLE MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN. ARE JUST SOME OF THE FEW
ISSUES AND BARRIERS THE
CALIFORNIANS STILL FACE IN THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SPACE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND AN OBLIGATION
TO FIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS AND EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY CAN STILL ACCESS HEALTH
CARE NO MATTER THEIR ZIP CODE.
THEIR GENDER OR THEIR COLOR.
TODAY WE STAND TOGETHER TO
SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL AMERICANS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR ONE TEN.
THANK YOU THEY HAVE AS FAR HAND.
MISS GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERS SHOULD BE LIKE TO BE
RECOGNIZED PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO I COULD SEE THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. I RISE IS THE FATHER
OF TWO DAUGHTERS. WHO I WANT TO
HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY IN WHO I
DON'T WANT EVER TO BE DENIED
THEIR RIGHTS. FOR FAR TOO LONG
WE KNOW IN THIS COUNTRY THAT.
THE WOMEN'S RIGHTS. TO SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS WERE VIOLATED
WERE PUT IN SECOND PLACE. AND.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY A LARGE
MOTIVATOR BEHIND A LOT OF I
THINK THIS DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE EARD TODAY. BUT I. I
ALSO RISE AS THE FATHER OF TWIN
BOYS. WHO CAME AT THIRTY WEEKS.
TEN WEEKS BEFORE THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO COME INTO THE WORLD.
I WAS WITH MY WIFE. IN UCSF.
WHEN THOSE TWIN BOYS WERE
SIXTEEN WEEKS ALONG. AND THEY
DID AN ECHO CARDIOGRAM TO CHECK
ON THEIR HEART BEATS. AND TO
SEE THEIR BLOOD FLOW. AND IF
THINGS WERE NOT GOING RIGHT
THEY WERE PREPARED TO DO
SURGERY. ON THOSE TO UNBORN
CHILDREN AND NOBODY IS EVER
GOING TO TELL ME THAT THEY ARE
NOT PEOPLE. THEY'RE NOT. THEY
WEREN'T PERSONS AT THAT POINT
IN TIME YOU DON'T DO SURGERY ON
INANIMATE OBJECTS. SO THIS IS
VERY REAL FOR ME. AS WELL AND
THIS IS WHAT WE TRY TO OVER
SIMPLIFY THIS ISSUE AND IT'S
REALLY JUST NOT THAT SIMPLE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY THE STRUGGLE THAT IS
GOING ON ACROSS THIS NATION.
IT'S A STRUGGLE THAT WAS
UNRESOLVED IN ROW I MEAN IF YOU
READ THE DECISION. YOU WILL SEE
THAT WHILE RECOGNIZING THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY. FOR WOMEN AND
TO MAKE A CHOICE ABOUT THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IT ALSO
RECOGNIZED THAT STATES DO HAVE
A LEGITIMATE INTEREST. WHEN A
FETUS BECOMES VIABLE WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH A CHILD. AND SO
THAT. IN RECENT YEARS HAS
BECOME A BIG DEBATE BECAUSE WE
SEE THAT. WE DO HAVE TO WE DO
HAVE A PERSON ANOTHER PERSON.
IT'S RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH HERE. IT ISN'T SIMPLY.
JUST A WOMEN'S RIGHTS ISSUE IT
IS ALSO. THE RIGHTS OF THIS I'M
OF UNBORN CHILDREN. AND SO
STATES ARE WRESTLING WITH THIS
QUESTION WHAT IS THE MORAL
RIGHT THING TO DO. HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THOSE RIGHTS. ARE
PROTECTED AS WELL. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THIS STATE.
ULTIMATELY HAVE TO WRESTLE WITH.
AS WELL. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE ROBUST CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS LESS US VERSUS THEM
CONVERSATIONS AND MORE REALLY
TRYING TO GET DOWN. TO THE
HEART OF ISSUES. AND TRY TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE RIGHTS
DUE PROCESS. MANY QUALITY FOR
ALL. AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
JUST A SIMPLE. ONE WHERE THE
OTHER DISCUSSION. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING AND I
JUST I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE OF A DISCUSSION ABOUT.
THOSE RIGHT SOME OF THE MOST
ARDENT. ADVOCATES PRO LIFE
ADVOCATES IN THIS DEBATE RIGHT
NOW ARE WOMEN SO WHEN I HEAR
THAT IS JUST MEN MAKING
DECISIONS THAT'S COMPLETELY
WRONG IN AN ACCURATE. WHILE A
ROSE IS ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE
ARTNET VOICES A WOMAN AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL TALKING ABOUT
THIS VERY THING. SO I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY THOSE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION WOMEN HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS. AND I THINK
WE SHOULD RESPECT THOSE
OPINIONS AND WE SHOULD HAVE.
AGAIN. A MORE IN DEPTH THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
IT'S NOT. THAT SIMPLE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MR MATHIS HERE
RECOGNIZE YES MISS YOUR
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE WE
SUPPORT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE BUT NOT PARENT RIGHTS. I
BELIEVE THIS RESOLUTION IS
ABOUT A SUPPORTING A WOMAN'S
ABILITY TO MAKE THE DECISION
FOR HERSELF. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION IS WICKS YOU
MAY CLOSE AND WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. YES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND THE FIRST OPENED A
ROLL CALL TO A- CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU. DAVIS WICKS FOR
SHALL BE ABLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CLUB LEVEL THE
ROLE. IS FOR CO AUTHORS CO
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE TEN. THIS IS
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEMBERS I
WANTED. CALL FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE GIVEN THE DISCUSSION THAT
ENSUED ON A RESOLUTION THIS
WILL BE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
ACR CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
THE AC ARE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE FIFTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE SOME GUESTS WHO ARRIVED
IN THE CHAMBER. UP IN THE
GALLERY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA AND GONZALES
PLEASE WELCOME GUESTS FROM SAN
DIEGO TINA CHASE AND KATHY
EIICHI THEY ARE SEATED IN THE
GALLERY WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I AM REFERRING AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD AND
A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY TWO ALSO
WOULD TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
TO TAKE UP THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM'S ITEM FOR
WHICH WE PASS TEMPORARILY. THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. AB.
THIRTEEN OH NINE. THE
CORPORATION AS LEGAL THIRTEEN
OH NINE BY SELLING MEMBER
BARRICADE HAN AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OKAY HAND
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY AB THIRTEEN NO
NINETIES BACK BEFORE YOU ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKING
IN THE SENATE REMOVED
OPPOSITION AND ESTABLISH THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF COVERAGE FOR
THOSE PURCHASING HEALTH
INSURANCE THROUGH COVERED
CALIFORNIA OR THE INDIVIDUAL
EXCHANGE AS FEBRUARY FIRST THIS
CHANGE WILL ELIMINATE LAPSES IN
COVERAGE FOR NEW ENROLLEES AB
THIRTEEN OH NINE HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THING AS
FAR CAN SEE NO DISCUSSION OF
BATES CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ROLE. TIED UP. I
FIFTY EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
EVER SAW THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS
SEVENTY. THROUGH SEVENTY SIX.
PASS AND RETAIN
. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO THE THIRD READING
FILE SENATE BILLS. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN SB SEVEN FIFTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
JOINT POWERS. THIS RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB SEVEN FIFTY ONE A
BILL THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE
GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS IN THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY BY
ESTABLISHING A CENTER VALLEY
REGIONAL HOUSING TRUST. THIS
BILL WILL ADDRESS THE CRISIS IN
THIS YEAR VALLEY BY AUTHORIZING
LOCAL CITIES AND THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES TO ENTER INTO A
JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT. TO
CREATE A REGIONAL HAPPENING
TRUSTS TO FUND THE PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS. SB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
IS SPONSORED BY THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND PASSED
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIRTY WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. NASA RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SB THREE THREE EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER
HUESO AND ACTON OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THAT
RISE PRISON SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HUESO A BILL WHICH JUST PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS FROM HARMING ABUSE.
SB THIRTY EIGHT WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR AND
DISABILITY JUSTICE ACT WHICH
WILL GIVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TOOLS TO BETTER
PROTECT SENIOR CITIZENS AND
CALIFORNIA'S LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES FROM ABUSE SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HATE
CRIMES AND MURDER. THIS BILL
WILL MAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AWARE OF ALL EXISTING
LAWS AND TOOLS TO PROTECT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
ARE ELDERS IT WAS STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THEM TO ADOPT
COMPREHENSIVE FORMAL POLICIES
ON THESE CRIMES BITING OFFICER
ON FORSMAN AND INCLUDING
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND
LOCALLY DEVELOPED
ACCOUNTABILITY PROTOCOLS. SB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NO BOTH
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD. COALITION
OF ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BOAT. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA. IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
VIOLATING EIGHTY ONE WILL PASS
THIRTEEN AND VIOLATE AND EIGHTY
TWO THREE FOUR PASSENGER CHAIN
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX PASS
TEMPORARILY OF VIOLATING EIGHTY
SEVEN. PASS TEMPORARILY A FILE
ITEM NINETEEN NINETY. EXCEPT
FOR A PATH RETAIN A BY LEN
NINETY ONE FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
SB ONE NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL ONE
NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR BELL
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. MR FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB ONE NINETY SEVEN
WILL MAKE PERMANENT THE CURRENT
PRO PROVISIONAL CALTRANS
WITHOUT WITHHOLDING ON OF
RETENTION PROCEEDS FROM PUBLIC
WORKS CONTRACTORS. RETAINING A
PERCENTAGE OF THE CONTRACTS OF
PROGRESS PAYMENTS UNTIL THE
CONTRACT IS COMPLETED FORCES
THE CONTRACTOR TO COMPLETE WORK
WITHOUT FULL PAYMENT AND CAN
FORCE THEM TO SELF FINANCE.
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. THIS
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
CONTRACTORS TO PAY THEIR DEBTS
AND EMPLOYEES IN A TIMELY
MANNER. WHICH CAN RESULT IN
HIGHER PROJECT COST AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE TAXPAYERS. IN
ADDITION TO SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM PROHIBITING THE
WITHHOLDING OF RETENTION
PROCEEDS. BRINGS PARITY WITH
FEDERAL RETENTION REQUIREMENTS
THE RESULTS IN LOW COST SAVINGS.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO REPORTED
ISSUE SINCE THE RIVER
PROHIBITION WAS FIRST ENACTED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES. HIGHER
DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS. NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE
FILE ITEM NINETY SIX SB TWO
FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN AND ACTION THE
LAND USE FORGET OR TO SEE THEIR
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE RISING PERCENT SB TWO FORTY
NINE ON BEHALF OF CENTER
NIELSEN HI THIS IS ALSO RELATED
TO THE RECOVERY OF THE CAMPFIRE
AS COMMUNITIES REBUILD SB TWO
FORTY NINE WILL ALLOW
LEGISLATIVE BODIES WITHIN BUTTE
COUNTY TO EXTEND THE LIFE OF
SUBDIVISION MAPS BY UP TO THREE
YEARS. THIS BILL WHAT IT EXTEND
THAT EXPRESSION A FOR ANY
TENTATIVE SUBDIVISION MAP OR
VESTING TENTATIVE MAP OR PARCEL
MAP WHICH RELIES ON THOSE MAPS
AND TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WE'VE
BEEN MADE WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON ON THE SPORT BILL SB
TWO FORTY NINE THANK YOU. YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NEWS HERE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE ON THE
BILL THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT REAL
SIXTY TWO WAY THE FALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT. TO ALLOW THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE HERE AB ELEVEN
SEVEN FIVE WOULD AND A. B.
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO WOULD
TOMORROW AT EIGHT THIRTY AM IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. WILL PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT EIGHT SB THREE
FIFTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL 359% OR MORE LOCK
AND OTHERS IN ACTING TO
ELECTIONS. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER NUMBER IS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE FIFTY NINE. THIS BILL
CREATES A SIMPLIFIED METHOD FOR
LOCAL REFERENDUMS CURRENTLY
CITY COUNCILS ARE ABLE TO FOR
CITIZENS CONDUCTING A PETITION
PETITION. TO INCLUDE THOUSANDS
OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS WHEN
GATHERING SIGNATURES. THIS
DRIVES UP COSTS REDUCES VOTER
PARTICIPATION AND INTIMIDATES
THOSE WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. SB
THREE FIFTY THREE FIFTY NINE
WILL ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
SIMPLY PROVIDING PROPONENTS
WITH THE STREAMLINED METHOD TO
FILE A REFERENDUM. THIS BILL IS
HAD BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE IT. THANK YOU MISS
BETWEEN OUR S. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRED. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS NINETY NINE
THROUGH ONE HUNDRED AND ONE.
HAS TO RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS.
ONE HUNDRED THREE THREE ONE
HUNDRED FOUR ASCERTAIN AND FILE
ITEMS. ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE HER EIGHT PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE AND
FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE PASS AND
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS ONE
THIRTEEN. THROUGH ONE NINETEEN
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN TO LECTURE CITY. SIR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN REQUIRES AN
ELECTRIC UTILITY DETERMINES HOW
IT WILL ADDRESS D. ENERGIES
ATION OF THE ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
LINES. OR MITIGATING THE
INTERRUPTION OF POWER TO
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE LIFE SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT. LAND WOULD NEED TO
BE REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THIS MEASURE IS
SUPPORTED BY FIRST RESPONDERS
UTILITIES SOCIAL WORKERS AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE SB FOUR THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FOR THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
UMBERG ACTUALLY CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE MISS SMITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF OF-SENATOR TOM UMBERG TO PRESENT
AS THE FOUR THIRTY NINE
SPONSORED BY THE LA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. SB
FOUR THIRTY NINE WOULD UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S WIRE TAP STATUTE
TO PERMIT THE USE OF A LAWFULLY
INTERCEPTED CONVERSATION TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE ANY
SERIOUS FELONY INVOLVING THE
DESTRUCTIVE DEVICES AND AFTER A
FIRE ARM ENSURING THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS ALL THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO KEEP US SAFE. AS
THE FOUR THIRTY NINE ALSO
EXTENDS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
PEACE OFFICERS BY PERMITTING
THE USE OF STATEMENTS INVOLVING
CRIMINAL OFFENSES MADE BY A
PEACE OFFICER IN AN
ADMINISTRATIVE OR DISCIPLINARY
HEARING INVOLVING THE
EMPLOYMENT OF A PEACE OFFICER
THIS BILL HAD RECEIVED VOTES.
AS THE FOUR THIRTY NINE IS A
BALANCED BILL THAT PROVIDES A
LOGICAL CLEAN UP TO THE PENAL
CODE DURING THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS THE NECESSARY
TOOLS NEEDED TO PURSUE
PROSECUTION OF SERIOUS FELONIES.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER. WORK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY TWO THROUGH
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ONE THIRTY ONE
TO ONE THIRTY TWO MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE SB
TEN THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL TEN BY SENATOR BELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MENTAL
HEALTH MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS
PRINCIPAL CALL AUTHOR I PRESENT
SB TEN WHICH IS DOUBLES AS A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST. APPEAR
PROVIDER IS A PERSON WHO HAS
EXPERIENCED MENTAL ILLNESS OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS THEY
HAVE BEEN THERE FORTY EIGHT
OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED PURE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS MEANING
THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED CLEAR
BASIC STANDARDS FOR PEER
TRAINING. EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
STATES USING PEERS REDUCE
IMPATIENT DAYS AND HOSPITAL
USAGE MEDICAID REIMBURSES 450%
OF THE COST OF SERVICES IN
STATES WITH CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS REDUCING THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON OUR COUNTY PROVIDERS.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE
APPEARS GET THE TRAINING THEY
NEED TO DO THEIR BEST WORK SB
TEN ENJOY STRONG BY PART.
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT ON ONE THIRTY FOUR SB
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL NINETEEN BY SENATOR
DODD AND OTHERS IT ACTUALLY TO
WATER RESOURCES MISTER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SB NINETEEN ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR DODD. THIS
BILL REQUIRES A DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO DEPLOY A NETWORK OF
STREAM GAUGES AND DETERMINE
FUNDING NEEDS FOR ACT
REACTIVATING EXISTING GAUGES
MENTION OUR WATER SUPPLIES
GROWING MORE CRITICAL AND
DIFFICULT TO GAPS IN STATE AND
READ WATER DEPTH UNFORTUNATE.
HAS LOST THE ABILITY TO MEASURE
STREAM FLOW AT BUT A VERY
IMPORTANT TYPE OF DATA 86% OF
THE STATE SIGNIFICANT STREAMS
ARE POORLY GAUGE RESTORING
STEEN STREAM STREAM GAGES IS AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT THE STATE
WIDE AND REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY IS A STRONG
COALITION OF SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETEEN AND I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER WOULD SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED THE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MR TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL
FORTY IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT THE HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED
LAST YEAR THROUGH SB TEN FORTY
FIVE. CAN BE IMPLEMENTED IN
ORDER TO SAVE LIVES SB FORTY
MAKES IMPORTANT TECHNICAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM FURTHER
SAFEGUARD CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
ENHANCE REPORTING TO THE COURTS
THIS BILL CONTAINS IMPORTANT
CONSTRAINTS AROUND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
THE BALANCE IS THE RESPECT FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL CIVIL LIBERTIES
WELL REQUIRE WHILE RECOGNIZING
THE DIRE SITUATION THE MANY
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR NEED FOR
STRUCTURED CARE. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
ONTHE URGENCY AYE AYES SIXTY
PHONE FOUR NO ZERO ON THE BILL
THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY EIGHT IT'S- PASS.
AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS. ONE
FORTY ONE AND ONE FORTY TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY THREE PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY FIVE AND
ONE FORTY SIX. TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY NINE AND
ONE FIFTY PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEMS ONE FIFTY ONE THROUGH ONE
FIFTY THREE MOVING A FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY FOUR SB TWO NINETY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR HILL ACTUALLY TO
TAXATION. THE BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
PRESENT AS BE TWO NINETY FOUR
WHICH WILL EIGHT NON PROFITS
AND RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BY EXPANDING THE EXISTING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION AS WELL
AS ALLOWED CHARITIES WITH AT
LEAST 50% LOW INCOME TENANTS TO
GET A PRO RATED PORTION OF THE
PROPERTY TAXES EXEMPTED. THIS
BILL IS NO OPPOSITION AND IS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT SO
FAR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE HE
DESIRED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERVE IT THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO THEIR
THIS MEASURE PASSES. PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY
SIXTY ONE FIFTY NINE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SB THREE
THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY
THE HOUSING. MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS THIS. ENSURES TIMELY
PROCESSING OF HOUSING PERMITS
THAT ARE ALREADY PERMISSIBLE
UNDER A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXISTING STONING ZONING AND
DESIGN STANDARDS. WHOOPS.
ZONING ZONING. RECOGNIZING THAT
OUR STATE'S HOUSING SHORTAGE
HAS LEFT ARE PEOPLE FACING SOME
OF THE HIGHEST RENTS AND HOME
PURCHASE COSTS IN THE COUNTRY
THIS BILL IS A SENSIBLE
APPROACH THAT HELP THE GREEN
LIGHT TO SING THAT ALREADY
MEETS LOW STANDARDS IT
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF HOUSING ADVOCATES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY NINE
KNOWS FOR THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
TWO SB THREE FIFTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
D'AMATO AND ACTUALLY THE
CLIMATE CHANGE. I MEAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR HURTADO I RISE 2% SB
THREE FIFTY ONE THIS BILL
REQUIRES A STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL TO CONSIDER PROJECTS
UNDERTAKEN AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN UNINCORPORATED
AREAS FOR IMPLEMENTATION GRANT
FUNDING TO THE TRANSFER THROUGH
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
DISADVANTAGE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES DESERVE A FAIR SHOT
TO MEET OUR STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS THIS BILL
IS CO SPONSORED BY LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL ON JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SAMPER VETO
COUNTY. THE BILL IS RECEIVED
PARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS GOTTEN
NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY NINE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE SIXTY THREE THROUGH ONE
SIXTY FIVE ASCERTAIN OF
VIOLENCE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THROUGH ONE SIXTY NINE. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE SB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ CYNICAL FOR TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE HEALTH.
SEGMENT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS BIGGER
MEMBERS I A RISE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR PAN. THE THIS
LEGISLATORS BE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES IN IMPROVING ACCESS
RESPONSE AND RESOURCES WHEN IT
COMES TO MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE WORK TO
DO ESPECIALLY WITH OUR YOUTH.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NEARLY ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SURVEYED
REPORTED FEELING SAD. OR
HOPELESS ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR
TWO OR MORE WEEKS IN A ROW
NEARLY ONE FIVE REPORTED THEY
HAVE SERIOUSLY. IT WAS A SB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WOULD ADDRESS
THE ADDRESS THE MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH WHERE THEY
SPEND MOST OF THEIR TIME ON
CAMPUS WAY QUIPPING TEACHERS
WITH THE TOOLS AND KNOWLEDGE
NOT ONLY TO IDENTIFY EARLY
SYMPTOMS AND SIGNS BUT TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS GET
TREATMENT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THIS BILL HAS REACHED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT PLEASE HELP
ME AND DOCTOR PAN IN ASSISTING
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF ALL KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA. BY SUPPORTING AS
BEFORE THE EIGHT TO IMPROVE
MENTAL HEALTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THANK YOU A
SEGMENT SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MAP THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE- NUMBERS.
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DOES
THAT. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM. ONE SEVENTY FIVE SB FOUR
FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FOR FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY A PEST CONTROL MAKING
A PREPARATION THEREFORE SAGGY
OCCUR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE CALIFORNIA
MAKES 81% OF ALL ONE IN AMERICA
AND WE ARE PROBABLY THE WORLD'S
FOURTH LEADING LINE PRODUCER
AND- ACTUALLY WINE GRAPES ARE
AT RISK. THESE PIERCE'S DISEASE
IS ONE THE MOST DEADLY WHICH IS
CAPABLE OF KILLING VINES WITHIN
JUST TWO YEARS TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH AND EFFORTS TO CONTROL
THE SPREAD OF PIERCE'S DISEASE
CALIFORNIA CREATED PIERCE'S
DISEASE CONTROL PROGRAM AND THE
PIERCE'S DISEASE AND GLASSY
WINGED SHARPSHOOTER BOARD IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE PROGRAM
AND THE BORDER FUNDED THROUGH
THE FEDERAL AND INDUSTRY FUNDS
AND WINE GRAPE GROWERS
ASSESSMENTS SB FOUR FORTY NINE
EXTENDS THE NURSES DISEASE
CONTROL PROGRAM TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TO CONTINUE
IMPORTANT RESEARCH EFFORTS TO
COME COMBAT THIS DEVASTATING
DISEASE. AND THE THREAT TO THE
WINE INDUSTRY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY
SIX AND ONE SEVENTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT SB FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ SAMPLE FOR EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
THE WATER RESOURCES. MR QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THE SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
IS A WONDERFUL BELL PLEASE VOTE
FOR IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER QUIRK. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRD VOTE. QUIRK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES BY LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
SB FIVE OH FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIVE OH FOUR
BY SENATOR MINING AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY HIGHWAYS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB FIVE
OH FOUR AUTHORIZES THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO
RELINQUISH TO THE CITY OF HIS
MOBILE EACH ABOUT TWO MILES OF
STATE HIGHWAY ROUTE ONE. THAT
IS WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRED. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SB FIVE THIRTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR TADO
AND OTHERS AND I FIND WATER
SERENA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB FIVE
THIRTEEN WILL HELP INSURE WATER
TANKS REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR
FAMILIES. IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
WITHOUT DRINKING WATER AS A
RESULT OF A DRY WELL IN
CALIFORNIA OVER TWELVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES HAVE NEEDED EMERGENCY
WATER TANKS AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC DROUGHT.
ALTHOUGH OUR STREETS DROUGHT
WAS DECLARED OVER IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WATER SHORTAGE IS A
COMMON SYMPTOM IN THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND MANY
FAMILIES WHO WENT STRIVE AFTER
APRIL TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
DID NOT QUALIFY FOR THE
TEMPORARY WATER TANKS. SB FIVE
THIRTEEN CODIFIES THAT FUNDING
FOR WATER TANKS ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY HOME IMPACTED BY A DRY
WELL OR DROUGHT AND CLARIFIES
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD MAY ASSUME
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR WATER
TANKS FOR HOMES WITH DR WELLS
OUTSIDE OF OUR EMERGENCY
DROUGHT DECLARATION. THIS BILL
ALSO CONFORMS THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED
FOR WATER TANKS AND IF BROWN'S
RELIEF MATTERS IN AB. SEVENTY
FOUR OUR BUDGET BILL RECENTLY
SIGNED AN EARNERS SOME. ACCESS
IS A ROOM RELIEF MEDICARE'S
FAMILIES WILL CONTINUE TO GO
WITHOUT CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER M. US SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS A RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS.
ONE EIGHTY ONE ONE EIGHTY THREE
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
EIGHTY FIVE AND ONE EIGHTY SIX
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN SB FIVE FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR ROTH
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. IF YOU'RE A
REAL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB FIVE FIVE FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ROTH THE BILL
WOULD PROVIDE A STREAMLINED
APPROACH FOR ADULTS ENROLLED IN
A HIGH SCHOOL A QUINCY PROGRAM.
TO CONCURRENTLY IN ROLE IN ONE
OR MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COURSES WITHOUT TUITION OR
FEES. SB FIVE FIVE FOUR
ENCOURAGES ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO CREATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
PATHWAYS INTO COLLEGE FOR
STUDENTS WITH HISTORICALLY LOW
LEVELS OF PARTICIPATION IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. SEARCH OF NATIONAL
AND STATE LEVELS TELLS US THAT
DUAL ENROLLMENT GRAMS ARE A
POWERFUL STRATEGY FOR
INCREASING COLLEGE SUCCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
AND NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BY ARTISANS
THROUGHOUT SAYS NO OPPOSITION
OUR CPAP REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
I WILL PASS THE RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
NINETY THREE ONE NINETY TWO ONE
NINETY FOUR THROUGH ONE NINETY
SEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT SB SIX ELEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL SIX
ELEVEN BY SENATOR CAFIERO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING
IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SIX ELEVEN ON BEHALF. OF A GYRO
SB SIX ELEVEN ESTABLISHES THE
HOUSING OLDER PERSONS
EFFECTIVELY OR HOPE. FORCE AS
PART OF THE STATE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING. WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE
BUT IS TAKEN IT EVEN GREATER
TOLL ON OR PROP ON ARE OVER.
SIXTY FIVE POPULATION WHO OFTEN
LIVE ON FIXED INCOMES. AS PART
OF THE AGING MASTER PLAN
PROCESS THE HOPE TASK FORCE
WILL CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY. POLICIES TO HELP
OLDER ADULTS AND THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AGE IN PLACE.
OPPORTUNITIES TO INTEGRATE
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES TO
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES. AND BEST
PRACTICES TO DEVELOP AN
INTERGENERATIONAL HOUSING THAT
INCLUDES SERVICES AND SUPPORT
IN ORDER. FOR SENIOR
POPULATION. NOW MORE THAN EVER
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A THOUGHTFUL
PLAN TO MEET THE GROWING NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING FOR OLDER ADULTS. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT. ALSO WOMAN COCKED
SPRITE THE BILL I ASK FOR YOUR
OF. THANK YOU ASIDE HERE CURRY
SEEINGAND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
AND SB SEVENTY ONE DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR. HOUSE
RESOLUTION THREE BY THE ONLY
MEMBER LIMóN AND OTHERS WILL
TO THE UNITED STATES WOMEN'S
NATIONAL SOCCER TEAM AND PAY
PARITY. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. UNDER ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINDER OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY NINE I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE I SEVENTY
ONE NEWS HERE AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO.
MEMBERS MISTER MCCARTY IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
HIS MEASURE THE CLERK WILL POST.
WHEN ACA SEX ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
FOCUS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR
NO SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
THE G. O. COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
TWO UPON A GERMAN OBSESSION THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER SIXTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM TOMORROW
MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
UPDATED YOUR
. MEMBERS PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I REAR REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS AB ONE SEVENTY
FOUR WOULD TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX IRWIN TO THE LABOR
COMMITTEE. MISTER CALDERON FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. UNDER
MODE MOTIONS OF COURSE OF
COURSE I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT REAL
SIX TO A THE FALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB ONE
SEVENTY FOUR WHAT TOMORROW AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ATE. IN THE ABSENCE
INTERJECTION WE WILL NOW LEFT
QUORUM CALL. AND MOVED TO THIS
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART. TODAY
THAT I'VE. YES WE CLOSE IN
MEMORY OF MARJORIE MCGILL WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY SEVEN LAST WEEK. HER
LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY TAKEN BY A
DERANGED INDIVIDUAL. WHILE
WORKING HER SECOND JOB AS A DOG
WALKER IN WASHINGTON DC. NEAR
WHERE SHE LIVED. MIGUEL WAS
WORKING AS A PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR THE UC DAVIS
WASHINGTON CENTER. WHERE SHE
HELP PLACE GRADUATE STUDENTS IN
INTERNSHIPS AT HOME AND ABROAD.
PRIOR TO THAT SHE HAD WORKED AS
AN INTERN AT THE JANE GOODALL
INSTITUTE. AFTER FINISHING HER
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AND THEN
SHE EARNED A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF WESTMINSTER IN
LONDON. BEFORE RECENTLY
RETURNING TO WASHINGTON DC. AND
EXPERIENCE GLOBAL TRAVELER
MCGILL'S PASSIONS INCLUDED
INTERNATIONAL AGRICULTURE FOOD
SECURITY. AND EMPOWERING WOMEN
AND STUDENTS. MARJORIE MCGILL
IS SURVIVED BY HER PARENTS AND
FFA ADVISORS JEFF AND BONNIE
MCGILL. AND HER SISTER RAY BAN.
IT WAS A INTERN IN MY OFFICE.
IN HER YOUTH MARJORIE DEVELOPED
A PASSION FOR AGRICULTURE WAS
INVOLVED IN FOUR H. AND FFA AND
RAISING GOATS. FFA WAS A HUGE
PART OF MARJORIE'S LIFE SHE
BELIEVE THE NAVY BLUE FFA
JACKETS. WAS LIKE A SECOND PART
OF YOU. SHE SAID YOU CAN'T TAKE
IT OFF AND PUT IT ON BUT IT
STILL STICKS WITH YOU FOREVER.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SHE
RECEIVED THE HIGHEST AWARD. IN
THE FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA
ORGANIZATION THE AMERICAN
FARMER DEGREE. MEMBERS ONLY 1%
OF FFA MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
RECOGNIZED WITHOUT HONOR. THAT
SAME YEAR MARJORIE SPENT TWO
WEEKS IN NICARAGUA IS PART OF
THE FEED BY SEED PROGRAM WHERE
SHE HELPED BUILD MODEL FARMS
AND TEACH CHILDREN ABOUT
AGRICULTURE. THERE WAS THIS
TRIP ABROAD THAT SOLIDIFIED.
HER FUTURE EDUCATIONAL AND
CAREER GOALS SHE WAS ONE OF
TWELVE STUDENTS CHOSEN FROM
APPLICANTS IN TWENTY THREE
STATES FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE INTERNATIONAL COLLEGIATE
AGRICULTURAL LEADERSHIP PROGRAM.
AS PART OF THIS PROGRAM SHE
TRAVEL TO VIETNAM MALAYSIA AND
SINGAPORE ON A TWO WEEK TRIP TO
STUDY INTERNATIONAL GREEN
MARKETING TRADE. AND GLOBAL
AGRICULTURE. HER FATHER SAID
THAT IT WAS HER PASSION. TO GO
TO OTHER COUNTRIES. AND SHARE
WITH PEOPLE HOW TO IMPROVE
THEIR FARMING PRACTICES. WE GO
RECEIVED A B. S. DEGREE IN
INTERNATIONAL AGRICULTURE
DEVELOPMENT UC DAVIS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHILE UC DAVIS SHE
VOLUNTEERED AS AN AGGIE
AMBASSADOR AND THE COLLEGE OF
AGRICULTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCES. CLEARLY. WE HAVE LOST
AN AMAZING PERSON AND
CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR SOCIETY AND
OUR WORLD. MCGILL WAS A
FRIENDLY OUTGOING A NATURAL
LEADER. OUR ENTIRE YUBA SUTTER
COMMUNITY IN THE UC DAVIS
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN STUNNED. BY
HER PATH. HER LIFE WILL BE
CELEBRATED ON OCTOBER
NINETEENTH AT THE YUBA SUTTER.
FAIRGROUNDS WHERE SHE SPENT SO
MUCH OF OUR TIME FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. ARE ENCOURAGED TO WEAR
PURPLE CONVERSE SHOES. THEN
CELEBRATE HER WONDERFUL LIFE
MEMBERS ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF MARJORIE MCGILL.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF A TRUE
PUBLIC SERVANT FORMER
CALIFORNIA SENATOR WHY THE DATA
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY SENATOR
DATA WAS BORN ON SEPTEMBER
SIXTH NINETEEN TWENTY IN
BAGHDAD IRAQ SO TOMORROW WOULD
BE HIS NINETY NINTH BIRTHDAY.
HE EARNED A DEGREE IN
LITERATURE FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF BAGHDAD. IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN HE EMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES WHERE HE BECAME A
NATURALIZED CITIZEN IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. AND THREE YEARS
LATER HE EARNED HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE.
SENATOR DATA HAD A FASCINATING
CAREER WORKING JOBS RANGING
FROM GROCERY STORE CLERK TO
OWNER OF AN ARABIC LINK THAT TO
US TO THE OWNER OF THE STORE.
AND A HAS AN ARABIC LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTOR AT ARMY LANGUAGE
SCHOOL IN MONTEREY WHERE HE MET
HIS WIFE MARILYN. HE ALSO
WORKED AS A CIVICS TEACHER AT
SWEETWATER HIGH SCHOOL AND A
POLITICAL SCIENCE PROFESSOR AT
SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE IN CHULA
VISTA. IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX HE
WON A SEAT IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. SENATOR DATA
BECAME ONE OF THE FIRST IRAQI
AMERICAN ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THE COUNTRY. HE SERVE SIXTEEN
YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY BEFORE
WINNING ELECTION TO THE STATE
SENATE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
IN THE LEGISLATURE SENATOR THAT
ARE WAS A- BI PARTISAN PROBLEM
SOLVER FOCUSING ON ISSUES WHERE
WE COULD REACH AGREEMENT
INSTEAD OF THE ISSUES THAT
DIVIDED US. HE ONCE TOLD HIS
HOMETOWN NEWSPAPER. THE WORD
COMPROMISE NEED NOT BE
OFFENSIVE TO PEOPLE. THIS IS
WHAT CIVILIZED PEOPLE DO. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE SENATOR DATA WAS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF PARTY
AFFILIATION EVEN LONG AFTER HE
LEFT PUBLIC OFFICE. IN FACT
WHEN I RAN FOR ASSEMBLY BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. SENATOR DATA
WAS ONE OF MY FIRST SUPPORTERS.
AND ENCOURAGE FROM MY CITY
COUNCIL ELECTIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND TWENTY TEN
SENATOR THAT I WAS THERE FOR ME.
WHEN I RAN FOR ASSEMBLY SENATOR
WAS THERE AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WHEN I WON THE SEAT. HE
WAS ALWAYS THERE FOR SUPPORT
AND HER IN ENCOURAGEMENT IN A
WAY THAT NO ONE ELSE COULD. HE
HAD BEEN THERE BEFORE. AND HE
HAD A GREAT WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
AND WISDOM FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LISTEN. PERHAPS HIS GREATEST
LEGACY IS THE CREATION OF
CALTRANS WHICH SHE PUSHED FOR
AS A WAY TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE
HE'S KNOWN FOR IS A FINANCING
TRANSPORTATION POLICY HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. SENATOR DATA
PASSED AWAY AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH JUST TEN DAYS BEFORE
HIS NINETY NINTH BIRTHDAY. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS MARY LYNN.
HIS SON PETER DATA THE
PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE SAN
DIEGO SUPERIOR COURT. HIS
DAUGHTER IN LAW A LATER THREE
GRANDCHILDREN TWO BROTHERS AND
ONE SISTER I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN THE TURNING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISTER
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED JUST
WANTED TO ADD A FEW OTHER
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF A VERY
LARGE AND LOYAL. CHALDEAN
COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT I'D
HAVE KNOWN. SENATOR WHAT HE
DOES I WAS THIS COLUMN WADIS SO
I'M GOING TO PASS ON THAT
SENATORS STUFF. I'VE KNOWN HIM
FOR YEARS HE'S HELP ME OUT
GREATLY HELPED ME GET INTO
POLITICS EVEN THOUGH IT WAS AN
OPPOSITE PARTY. AND THE THING
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS A CONSTITUENT
COULD CALL A MOP ANGRY. MAD
RELEASE HOT UNDER THE COLLAR.
WHAT DO WE GO OKAY OKAY KEEP
TALKIN. I'M LISTENING KEEP
TALKING. WEIRD AFTER ABOUT
THREE MINUTES YOU WANTED TO
PULL WEEDS IN THE GUYS FRONT
YARD HE HAD THAT ABILITY HE WAS
WONDERFUL IN THE CHALDEAN
COMMUNITY BUT HE WAS A BRIDGE.
BECAUSE PARTS OF HIS DISTRICT
WHETHER SENATOR OR ASSEMBLY WAS
VERY CONSERVATIVE AND HE WORKED
WITH EVERYBODY EQUALLY AND- YOU
HAD THE FEELING YOUR ISSUES
WERE JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
OPPOSITE ISSUES AND HE WOULD
WORK IT THROUGH. A GREAT MAN
GREATLY MISSED GOD BLESS THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER OF HOW MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO RISE
IN HONOR OF WHAT A DATA WHO MY
NEW IN MY YOUTH. AS YOU SERVE
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN
CONTINUED ON AND THE STATE
SENATE. JUST A VERY PERSONABLE
GENTLEMAN JOHN WAS VERY MUCH
WORRY WAS SOCIAL WITH WATER A
DAY OUT OF THE WAY HE-
CONDUCTED HIMSELF IN THIS BODY.
HE HAD A GREAT IT WITH PEOPLE
IN A SENSE OF HUMOR. IT WAS
INNER WOVEN JUST WITH THE WAY
HE INTERACTED WITH PEOPLE. AND
I THINK THAT'S A PART OF HIS
SUCCESS AS A VERY A COLLEGIAL
MEMBER WORK WITH ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE. I DO WANT
TO KIND OF GIVE HIM A SHOUT OUT
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES
HE CHAIRED THE SENATE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
HE HAD ALSO CHAIR THAT
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY. IN
THE AREA IN WHICH HE CHAIRED IN
THE SENATE. IT WAS AN ERA IN
WHICH YOU PROP SAW PROBABLY.
THE MOST PROFOUND OUTPOURING OF
A BODY OF LAW ENACTED. OVER A
SPAN OF FOUR YEARS THERE WERE
ALMOST TWENTY BILLS ADOPTED
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR. DEALING
WITH VARIOUS FACETS OF THE
PENSION SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSIONS BALLOT
PROPOSITIONS ROLE TO ENACTED BY
THE VOTERS WHICH FUNDAMENTALLY
STRENGTHENED THE PENSION
SYSTEM. SO VERY DEFINITELY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WHILE ENJOYING
THE LUSTER OF OFFICE WAS VERY
FOCUSED ON POLICY AND BY DINT
OF HIS EFFORT HIS LEADERSHIP.
HAD A TRANSFORMATIVE IMPACT ON
MANY FIELDS THE PENSION FEEL AS
I NOTE WE'RE ACTUALLY ALSO
EARLY IN HIS CAREER WAS THE
FATHER OF CALTRANS AS YOU MOVE
CALIFORNIA FROM A JURISDICTION
WHERE ROAD WORK WAS DONE BY
PUBLIC WORKS AGENCY. TO AN
ORGANIZED ADMINISTERED CALTRANS
AGENCY THAT TOO WAS THE WORK OF
WATER AGAIN SO VERY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL VERY COLLEGIAL
INDIVIDUAL BUT QUITE A TRACK
RECORD OF ACCOMPLISHMENT. AND
THIS IS THE SORT OF MEMBER THAT
DID HIS WORK AND BROUGHT PEOPLE
ALONG AS HE JUST WERE ABLE TO.
REYES WHAT HE HAD DONE AND NOD
THEIR HEAD AND VOTER HIGH.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
THRANDUIL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. I RISE
WITH A HEAVY HEART TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF RUSSELL
RUSTY SEE WORKS. RUSTY PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY LAST WEEK IN
SAN FRANCISCO AT THE AGE OF
SIXTY EIGHT AFTER A THREE YEAR
COURAGEOUS BATTLE WITH ALS. AS
A PROFESSIONAL ADVOCATE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS RUSTY WORKS TIRELESSLY ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN OUR STATE. IS
EXTENSIVE NOT OF THE HEALTH
CARE LEGISLATION AND FINANCES
HAS PUT HIM AT THE CENTER OF
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
POLICY WORK THAT OUR STATE HAS
DONE. AND CREATED A AVENUE FOR
HIM TO BE A PATIENT CARE
ADVOCATE. ONE OF RUSTY'S MOST
SIGNIFICANT CAREER TRIUMPHS WAS
THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY THREE
THAT HE WAS THE CO AUTHOR OF
ALONG WITH MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. WHICH WAS PASSED
INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
THAT PROPOSITION GENERATES TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY WHICH
HAS BEEN INVESTED AND IS
TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION END
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA RUSTY
HAS BEEN A LEADING EXPERT IN
MENTAL HEALTH AND STATE FINANCE
AS WELL AS STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT POLICY. HE ALSO
SERVED ON AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES A STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATIONS DEDICATED TO
HELPING WITH BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. RUSTY
CHALLENGED THOSE AROUND HIM TO
INCREASE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SIGNIFICANCE TOLL THAT
MENTAL HEALTH HAS AND CAN HAVE
IN BOTH THEIR OWN LIVES THEIR
FAMILY LIVES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. HIS ADVOCACY
RESULTED IN LESS STIGMATA AND
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. TODAY I
HONOR RUSTY AND HIS MORE THAN
THREE DECADES OF EXTRA ORDINARY
SERVICE. HIS EFFORTS HAVE
ESTABLISHED IN SUPPORT OF THE
INNOVATIVE MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. RIGHT WE
NEED TO BOTH CREATE AND CONNECT
WITH A DIVERSE COMMUNITY OF
STAKEHOLDERS HAS IMPACTED THE
SYSTEM AND CHANGE LIVES. RUSTY
DEVOTED HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE
TO SERVING OTHERS GIVING A
VOICE TO THOSE WHO DID NOT HAVE
ONE. HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A
LASSEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE USED
HIS POLITICAL EXPERTISE TO
GARNER SIGNIFICANT STATE
FUNDING FOR WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. IN CLINICAL CARE FOR
THOSE LIVING WITH EHLERS. RUSTY
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR THE
TIRELESS WORK THAT HE HAS DONE
IN MENTAL HEALTH AND IS NEVER
ENDING. DEVOTION TO THE
UNDERSERVED. HIS LIFE WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR THE GOOD THAT HE
HAS DONE. THE LOVE HE HAD FOR
HELPING OTHERS AND THE DEVOTION
TO HIS FAMILY AND TO HIS
FRIENDS. HIS WISDOM WILL REMAIN
HIS LEGACY. AND HE WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH HIS BELOVED
WIFE WITH HIS FAMILY. WITH HIS
CHILDREN AND WITH HIS FRIENDS.
I ASKED RESPECTFULLY THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF RUSTY
SEE LEX TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
ARAMBULA MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF A. B. LOVE TO
ACTRESS A REMARKABLE WOMAN.
EMMY AWARD WINNING ACTRESS
VALERIE HARPER WHO PASSED AWAY
LAST FRIDAY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY. HARPER WAS BEST KNOWN
FOR HER ROLE AS MARY TYLER
MOORE'S SMART ALIKI BEST FRIEND
RHODA IN THE CLASSIC NINETEEN
SEVENTIES SITCOM. THE MARY
TYLER MOORE SHOW. SHE WON THREE
CONSECUTIVE BEST SUPPORTING
ACTRESS AND THESE FOR THAT ROLE
AND RECEIVED A FOURTH AS
OUTSTANDING LEAD ACTRESS INNER
SPIN OFF SERIES RHODA. HARPER'S
CHARACTER FOUND GREAT
POPULARITY DUE TO HER ABILITY
TO PLAY A WOMAN WHO WAS FUNNY
GENUINE IT AT TIMES ON CERTAIN
OF HERSELF BUT ALWAYS THE KIND
OF PERSON YOU WANTED TO HAVE AS
YOUR BEST FRIEND. THESE ARE
ALSO QUALITIES THAT PEOPLE WHO
KNEW WHERE SAID THE COULD BE
USED TO DESCRIBE HER AS AN
INDIVIDUAL. HARPER WAS BORN IN
NEW YORK ON AUGUST TWENTY
SECOND NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
AND AS A YOUNG GIRL SHE KNEW
SHE WANTED TO BECOME A
PERFORMER AND- SHE BEGAN BY
TAKING DANCE LESSONS WHICH BY
THE TIME. SHE WAS SIXTEEN HAD
LANDED HER A PLACE AT THE
FAMOUS RADIO CITY MUSIC HALL
AND LATER IN THE CHORUS LINE OF
SEVERAL BROADWAY MUSICALS. SHE
THEN STUDIED DRAMA OF
EVENTUALLY MOVING TO LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
WHERE HER CAREER PATH TOOK HER
TO A ROLE AS RHODA. BUT ACTING
WAS NOT ALL THAT HARPER BECAME
KNOWN FOR. FOLLOWING A LUNG
CANCER DIAGNOSIS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE DESPITE HAVING
NEVER BEEN A SMOKER. SHE
DECIDED THAT SHE NEEDED TO WORK
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC AND ESPECIALLY WOMEN ON
THE DANGERS OF SECONDHAND
SMOKE. UNFORTUNATELY IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN SHE LEARNED THE CANCER
HAD SPREAD TO HER BRAIN. AND
SHE WAS TOLD AT THAT TIME. THAT
SHE WAS ONLY GONNA LIVE FOR
ANOTHER THREE MONTHS. AND
DESPITE THIS DEVASTATING
DIAGNOSIS AND THE INTENSE
CHEMOTHERAPY THAT FOLLOWED
HARPER RESPONDED BY RETURNING
TO WORK LATER DATE THAT SAME
YEAR. AND THIS WORK INCLUDED A
STINT ON DANCING WITH THE
STARS. ON A SHOW CALLED HOT IN
CLEVELAND AND STARRING IN AN
EPISODE ALONG MANY OF HER WHERE
WHERE SHE STARRED. AS SHE ALSO
STARRED IN AN EPISODE ALONG
MANY STE ALONGSIDE MANY EVER
MARY TYLER MOORE COSTARS.
HARPER ALSO BECAME A POLITICAL
ACTIVIST WHO WORKED FOR MANY
PROGRESSIVE IN CHARITABLE
CAUSES INCLUDING WOMEN'S RIGHTS
AND THE FIGHT AGAINST HUNGER.
SHE ALSO SPOKE OUT ON THE ISSUE
OF AGING INCLUDING OUR
CULTURE'S OBSESSION WITH YOUTH.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF WOMEN AND
SOCIETY NOT FEARING GETTING
OLDER. HARPER FACE THE REALITY
OF HER CANCER DIAGNOSIS WITH
COURAGE AND WISDOM AND OVER
OFTEN SPOKEN INTERVIEWS ON
TELEVISION URGING PEOPLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR LIVES
WELL THEY HAVE THE TIME TO DO
SO. SHE WAS QUOTED AS SAYING. I
REALLY WANT AMERICANS AND ALL
OF US TO BE LESS AFRAID OF
DEATH. HARPER SURVIVED SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND TONY CATCH JADI
AND HER DAUGHTER CRISTINA
CATCHY IDEA AND I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM MISS EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY WITH
A HEAVY HEART TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY APART GET SAYING. I'D
LIKE TO SAY MR SINGH DIED
PEACEFULLY IN HIS HOME AFTER A
LONG ILLNESS BUT I CAN'T. I
HAVE TO SAY ON SUNDAY AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH MR SINGH DIED
VIOLENTLY AFTER A WALK IN THE
PARK ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON. MR
SAYING IMMIGRATED TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM INDIA IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HE LEAVES
BEHIND A WIFE A DAUGHTER A SON
IN LAW AND THREE GRANDCHILDREN.
LIKE MANY IN THE C. COMMUNITY
MR SAYING AND HIS FRIENDS WOULD
OFTEN WALK IN THE PARK ON
EVENINGS EVENING WALKS AROUND A
PARK. GRETCHEN TALLY PARKING
TRACY A SAFE PLACE TO WALK
NORMALLY. AND AS HE BROKE OFF.
ON HIS WAY HOME. SEMI JUMPED
OUT AND STABBED HIM. WITHIN
FIVE STEPS HE FELL TO THE
GROUND AND DIED. TRACY
COMMUNITY GRIEVES HIS LOSS HIS
FAMILY GRIEVE HIS LOSS AND I
THINK WE ALL GRIEVE THE LOSS OF
CIVILITY. THAT PEOPLE CAN'T GO
FOR A WALK IN THE PARK WITHOUT
FEARING FOR THEIR VERY SAFETY
IN A PLACE THAT IS OTHERWISE. A
SAFE PLACE TO WALK. WE DON'T
KNOW THE MOTIVE FOR THIS CRIME
SOMEBODY HAS BEEN ARRESTED WE
DON'T KNOW THE MOTIVE FOR THIS
CRIME BUT WE KNOW. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVEN VIOLENT ATTACKS. ON
PEOPLE WHO WEAR TURBANS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. MR STICK WITH A
TURBAN WEARING SEEK GENTLEMAN.
AND WE WISH HIS FAMILY AND HIS
COMMUNITY PEACE AND I HOPE FOR
ALL OF US WE CONTINUE IN THE
TRADITION. OF WELCOMING. OF
LACK OF THE BUSINESS OF PEOPLE
COMING TOGETHER OF US REALLY
TRULY BEING THE PLACE WHERE
EVERYBODY IS SAFE WHERE PEOPLE
CAN COME. WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS AND HAVE THE
RESPECT AND THE SAFETY THAT
THEY DESERVE MR SEEK WAS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE TRACY
STATE COMMUNITY WHERE HE SERVE
FOOD AT THE TEMPLE. YOU
VOLUNTEERED ON FOURTH OF JULY
HANDING OUT FOOD AND WATER I
ATTENDED THE VIGIL THAT WE HAD
AND TRACY HAD. MET WITH HIS
FAMILY. THEY STAND READY TO BE
EMBRACED THEY STAND READY FOR
ALL OF US TO SHARE IN THEIR
GRIEF AND ALL OF US TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON OUR COMMITMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA BE A PLACE. OF
SAFETY AND FREEDOM. FOR
EVERYBODY. ON BEHALF. OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTEEN THE
COMMUNITY OF TRACY. THE SIX
COMMUNITY OF TRACY I MISTER
PARK IT SINGS FAMILY WE ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS TO GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO DOUBLE
RECOGNIZE THIS THIS TRAGIC LOSS
OF LIFE. AND TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MISTER PRIME SHEET
SAYING. IT'S ALWAYS A TRAGEDY
WAS SOMEONE'S LIFE WAS CUT
SHORT IS ONLY SIXTY TWO YEARS
OLD WAS. HERE TO VISIT WITH
ISN'T A NOT BITTER TO COME AND
STAY WITH HIS SON AND SPEND
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY BUT ALSO
AS A FARMER FROM JOB. TO LEARN
ABOUT THE IRRIGATION SYSTEM
HERE AND THE ABUNDANCE OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT OUR FARMERS HAVE
AND WHAT HE COULD DO TO TAKE
THAT KNOWLEDGE TO. MAKE LIFE A
BIT BETTER FOR THOSE BACK HOME
IN THE SAME INDUSTRY AND THOUGH
AND I KNOW WE HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS HERE THAT ARE FROM
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES LIKE
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM. THE
STOCKTON WHO UNDERSTAND HOW
DIFFICULT A LIFE IT IS AND HOW
HARD THOSE IN IN THE FARMING
INDUSTRY WORK AND MR SAYING.
CAME HERE AND I BY ALL ACCOUNTS
AS INDICATED BY A COLLEAGUE.
WAS A LOVING MAN OF THAT THAT
SPENT SO MUCH TIME GETTING. AND
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T KNOW THE
MOTIVATIONS OF THIS CRIME AS
INDICATED BY A COLLEAGUE. THIS
IS JUST BECOMING ON. THAT WERE
STAYING WITH THIS A COMMUNITY.
OF THOSE PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT WEARING THAT WHERE THEIR
ARTICLES OF FAITH. THAT ARE OUT
TAKING A WALK THAT ARE JUST
DOING THINGS THAT ALL OF US. DO
AND- IN IN ENJOYING THIS
BEAUTIFUL PLACE WE CALL HOME
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND TO DIE
SUCH A VIOLENT DEATH. IS
UNCONSCIONABLE. AND IT'S ONE
MORE REMINDER OF WHY WE'RE HERE
WHY WHAT WHY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE. TO FIGHT AGAINST THE
HATRED AND THE DEBATES OF NESS
THAT IS BEING CREATED IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT TRICKLES DOWN TO
OUR OWN NEIGHBORHOODS. AND SO I
CERTAINLY SEND ALL THE LOVE AND
PRAYERS TO THE FAMILY. I KNOW
THIS A COMMUNITY THE SECURITY
AND TRACY CERTAINLY. I WILL BE
EMBRACING THIS FAMILY FOR MANY
YEARS TO COME BUT I HOPE THAT
ALL OF US. I WILL GO TO DO THE
SAME AND PLEASE OF A TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES IF YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. VISIT THE AND
EMBRACE THE SECURITY CLOSEST TO
YOU THE GOOD WATER CLOSEST TO
AND YOU'LL SEE YOU'LL BE
WELCOMED. QUITE WARMLY AS MR
SAYING BUT WELCOME SO MANY WHEN
HE VOLUNTEERED. AT THE GROWTH
WATER IN HIS COMMUNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SWITCH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF GEORGE ROMERO. A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
BERKELEY WHO PASSED AWAY ON
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH AT THE AGE OF
ONE HUNDRED AND ONE. BORN
CALIFORNIAN RACE IN ITALY.
GEORGE JOIN THE ITALIAN
PARTISAN FORCES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE **** IN THE FASCISTS IN
WORLD WAR TWO. IT IS PART OF
THE NEXT INCLUDED ASSISTING
DOWNED AMERICAN ENGLISH PILOTS
AND AS AN ENGLISH SPEAKER
GEORGE ALSO ASSISTED THE ALLIES
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO CAPTURE
NORTHERN ITALY. AFTER THE WAR
GEORGE RECEIVED A CERTIFICATE
OF PATRIOT BY THE SUPREME
COMMANDER OF THE ALLIED FORCES
IN THE MEDITERRANEAN. HE ALSO
MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE. ARENA
GREGORIO AFTER THE WAR. EIGHT
ON APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN GEORGIAN KATERINA
WERE TOGETHER FOR SIXTY FIVE
YEARS UNTIL HER DEATH IN AUGUST
OF TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
GEORGE WAS A LIFELONG PACIFIST
AN ENVIRONMENTALIST DEDICATED
TO WORKING FOR PEACE AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE HE NEVER MISS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND AN ANTI
WAR PROTEST TO HELP THE LESS
FORTUNATE OR TO EDUCATE OTHERS
ON THE CLIMATE CRISIS. WHEN HE
WAS IN HIS EIGHTIES HE STARTED
COLLECTING SURPLUS SPREAD FROM
THE ACME BAKERY BERKELEY AND
DELIVERED IT DAILY TO HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND SOUP KITCHENS IN
THE EAST BAY FOR TEN YEARS.
GEORGE IS SURVIVED BY HIS SON'S
MARCELLO AND GUIDO SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. I ASK OF THIS
HOUSE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU MISS WAX
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK THREE PRINT TO THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS FOR
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MR FRAZIER MOVE SAN
MISTER LACKEY SECONDS THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER SIXTH AT NINE
AM. OUR QUE HAN VOTE CHANGE AB
SIXTEEN OH FIVE. FROM I TO
KNOW. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN IS ONLY
ABLE SIXTEEN OH FIVE I TO KNOW.
ROGER. THE CASE IN THE MEMBER
LACKEY VOTE CHANGE AB SIXTEEN
OH FIVE I DON'T KNOW. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AS A LEGAL SIXTEEN OH FIVE ICE
NOW. FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE A.
B. SIX TWENTY FOUR WALDRON ALL
RIGHT TO KNOW. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON IS ONLY
ABLE SIX TWENTY FOUR I TO NOW.
FILE ITEM THIRTY ITEM NO. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY I TO
KNOW. MADE MAIENSCHEIN A BEAST.
CORRECTION VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY HI IT'S NOW.
MAIENSCHEIN AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE
I TO KNOW. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN SOME
LEGAL SIXTEEN OH FIVE I TO KNOW
AND SB THREE THIRTY I TO NOW.
THE CHANGES IN THEIR
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY I TO KNOW. OF ALL THE
CHANGE AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE
I TO NOT VOTE. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG SUNNY WILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE I IT'S
NOT VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
FRAZIER. AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE NO
TO YES. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER ASSEMBLE
EIGHTEEN A ONE NOTE I. IRWIN AB
TEN THIRTEEN NO TÁI. THE
CHANGES A MEMBER IRWIN ASSEMBLY
WILL TEN THIRTEEN NOTE I. THE
CHANGE PETRIE-NORRIS AB AT
SIXTEEN OH FIVE I TO NOW. COULD
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AS LABEL SIXTEEN
OH FIVE I TO NOW. BURKE WILL
CHANGE SB THREE THIRTY I IT'S
NOT VOTING. THE CHANGES LINE
NUMBER SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
I IT'S NOT VOTING